Diese Klänge deuten es schon an. Déjà vu, letzter Mittwoch im Monat. Zeit fürs Chaos Radio mit dem Chaos Computer Club auf Fritz. Herzlich willkommen, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz und Déjà vu nicht nur, weil die Musik heißt, dass wir im Chaos Radio sind, sondern die Musik, die im Hintergrund läuft, Kraftwerk, erinnert uns auch daran, dass wir über ein Thema reden, was wir hier in dieser Sendung schon mal hatten. Und zwar im Januar. Da war es nur die Diskussion darüber, was sein wird. Jetzt ist es aktuell. Es geht um die Internetsperren. Der Aufhänger natürlich, Kinderpornografie im Netz. Wir alle und auch diese Sendung und auch der CCC sind sich einig. Der Missbrauch von Kindern ist eine widerliche, widerwärtige Sache. Dagegen muss was gemacht werden. Aber das, was gerade geplant wird in dem Gesetzentwurf, ist doch alles sehr merkwürdig. Der Gesetzentwurf heißt, dass das Bundeskriminalamt eine Liste hat mit Links zu Seiten, die Kinderpornografie anbieten, beziehungsweise mit Links, wo man dann dahin kommt. Die Provider, die Netprovider sind verpflichtet oder haben sich jetzt verpflichtet, mehr oder weniger freiwillig diese Seiten zu sperren. Und wenn auf diese Seiten zugegriffen wird, dann landet man automatisch bei einem Stoppschild, wie man es auch aus dem Straßenverkehr kennt, auf dem dann steht, sie wollen auf einer Seite zugreifen, die gesperrt ist. Und das Bundeskriminalamt wird über diesen Zugriff auf diese Seite informiert. Soweit die Theorie. Jetzt muss noch der Bundestag zustimmen. Und wenn das alles durch ist, dann Halleluja. Die weit verbreiterte Meinung ist, klar ist es richtig, dass was gegen Kinderpornografie gemacht wird. Es gibt aber genauso viel Kritik, wenn nicht sogar noch mehr, an diesem Gesetz. Das Hauptargument der Kritiker. Es geht hier gar nicht um Kinderpornografie, sondern es geht eigentlich um ein Werkzeug, was installiert werden soll, um das Internet mit den verschiedensten Inhalten zu zensieren. Was da alles dranhängt, das können uns Nibbler und Andreas vom CCC erklären. Die sind hier. Guten Abend, ihr beiden. Was hat denn dieses Handybrummen hier? Kurze Zusammenfassung von euch, um die Kritikerposition zu erklären. Was hat denn dieses Internetzensurgesetz damit zu tun, dass es eigentlich um Zensur von Inhalten geht und nicht nur um Kinderpornografie?
Also, unsere Kritik richtet sich eigentlich an zwei Punkte. Das erste ist die Art und Weise, wie es zustande gekommen ist, dass hier ein privater Vertrag abgeschlossen wird zwischen Internetanbietern und der Regierung. Glücklicherweise ist es mittlerweile so, dass über eine gesetzliche Grundlage diskutiert wird. Das ist ein guter Anfang, denn es handelt sich dabei, wenn man Kommunikation verhindert, um einen Eingriff in ein Grundrecht, nämlich das Grundrecht auf Informations- und Meinungsfreiheit, Artikel 5 Grundgesetz. Und es ist einfach nicht zulässig, ein solches Grundrecht einzuschränken, selbst wenn es für einen guten Zweck ist, ohne dass es dafür eine gesetzliche Grundlage gibt. Also, es geht damit ganz handwerklichen, wie die da nur sehr gemacht werden, wo wir uns sicherlich zu Recht auch aufgeregt haben darüber, dass hier schlicht und ergreifend das Handwerkszeug nicht verstanden wird, dass hier die, ja doch, emotional große Erregung beim Umgang mit dem Thema ausgenutzt wird, um etwas durchzusetzen, was eigentlich nicht so ganz in unsere demokratische Gesellschaft passt.
Wobei jetzt natürlich sofort Leute sagen, Moment mal, wenn es gegen Kinderpornografie geht, ist es doch eindeutig vereinbar mit der demokratischen Grundordnung. Denn hier wird eine Straftat verhindert oder bekämpft. Das ist eine Meinung, die hier vorherrscht.
Was sicherlich richtig ist, ist, dass auch Grundrechte von Kindern hier betroffen sind, nämlich Kinder haben das Recht auf körperliche Unversehrtheit und was sich aus der Menschenwürde ergibt. Und wir haben es sicherlich hier mit einer Grundrechtsabwägung zu tun. Das heißt, das eine Grundrecht und das andere Grundrecht, die kollidieren miteinander. Das ist aber nun nichts, was ungewöhnlich und neu ist, sondern es gibt eine Art und Weise, das zu regeln, nämlich muss dann eine Abwägung getroffen werden, ob die Beschneidung des einen Grundrechts, die gerechtfertigt ist, dadurch, dass das andere Grundrecht geschützt wird. Dazu muss aber zwingend Voraussetzung sein, dass dieses andere Grundrecht tatsächlich davon profitiert. Und da richtet sich unsere andere Kritik dagegen, dass nämlich die Maßnahmen, die da getroffen werden sollen, gar nicht wirksam sind, den Missbrauch von Kindern zu verhindern und damit auch schon wieder grundgesetzwidrig.
Und dass man vor allem andere Dinge tun könnte oder hätte können, bevor man mit so einer Keule kommt, die noch dazu nicht wirklich wirksam ist.
Weil, worüber gesprochen wird, ist das Website, das haben wir kurz angesprochen, die solche Inhalte anbieten, dass die gesperrt werden, weil die auf einer Sperrliste stehen und die Provider müssen das sperren. Aber es gibt ja schon, das haben wir in der Januarsendung übrigens auch ausführlich erläutert, falls euch das interessiert, chaosradio.ccc.de klicken. Da gibt es den Podcast von der Januarsendung, da könnt ihr noch mal reinhören. Eigentlich sind die rechtlichen Grundlagen ja da. Es gibt einen Anbieter solcher Sachen. Jeder Mensch, du, ich, wir alle, kann dem Provider eine Mail schreiben oder anrufen und kann sagen, da gibt es bedenkliches Material. Und relativ schnell sind diese Seiten dann vom Netz. Das ist in Dänemark zum Beispiel passiert. Das heißt, die rechtlichen Grundlagen, um sowas zu verhindern, sind ja eigentlich schon da. Also noch mal andersherum gefragt, was wird uns denn jetzt hier gerade unter dem Deckmantel des Kinderpornografieverbots, was wird uns denn hier eigentlich gerade verkauft? Neben Wahlkampf, ja.
Da geht es natürlich einerseits darum, sich zu profilieren. Das ist ein Thema, mit dem man sich als Familienministerin zum Beispiel schon Presse verschaffen kann. Möglicherweise hat Frau von der Leyen nicht abgesehen, was sie da tut und was es für ein Echo haben wird. Das ist ein bisschen schiefgegangen. Aber das steckt sicherlich dahinter. Und auf der anderen Seite steckt dahinter aber auch die schleichende Etablierung von Filtern im Internet, von Sperrung von Seiten. Und was wir im Januar noch spekuliert haben, dass sicherlich bald die Nächsten kommen und auch Seiten gesperrt haben wollen, das wird jetzt Wirklichkeit. Also die Diskussion über die Sperrung von zum Beispiel ausländischen Anbietern von Pferdewetten oder ähnlichen Glücksspielgeschichten, die findet jetzt statt. Es gibt Rufe, die laut werden, doch die Internetfilter einzusetzen, um das Kopieren von urheberrechtsgeschützten Materialen mit Internet zu verhindern. Also da wird auch ein Stück weit ein Tor geöffnet für weitere Begehrlichkeiten. Jeder möchte, dass gesperrt wird, was in manchen Ländern auch seltsame Blüten treibt.
Stichwort, um das kurz nochmal zurückzuholen, Stichwort Autobahn-Maut. Da hieß es ja auch am Anfang, die Mautbrücken und die Auswertung der Daten, die da gesammelt werden, sind nur dazu da, um die Maut zu erheben. Mittlerweile gibt es eine Kennzeichenerfassung, alles, was dazu kommt. Im Zuge dieses Gesetzes, was jetzt ein Gesetzentwurf ist, gibt es z.B. von der Bildungsministerin Frau Schavan schon die Anregung, dass man auch Gewaltseiten im Internet, was auch immer das jetzt im Speziellen heißt, dass man die gleich mal wegfiltern könnte. Dann kam Herr Gorni vom Bundesverband Musikindustrie und sagte, da kann man ja gleich auch mal sich Seiten greifen, die also Urheberrechte verletzen, Stichwort BitTorrent, Stichwort was auch immer da alles sein könnte. Es gibt also immer mehr Befindlichkeiten und Begehrlichkeiten, dieses Tool zu nutzen. Das kann dann im schlimmsten Fall, um jetzt mal ein Szenario zu kreieren, im schlimmsten Fall auch dazu führen, dass dein, mein, unser kleines Weblog plötzlich nicht mehr erreichbar ist, weil da Dinge drinstehen, die irgendeiner offiziellen Stelle nicht gefallen. Könnte das so weit gehen oder ist das jetzt Schwarzmalerei?
Damit ist eigentlich zu rechnen, dass das passieren wird. Wir haben schon im Vorfeld gesehen, dass eine Seite im Internet namens Wikileaks ein Portal ist, auf dem man Informationen veröffentlichen kann, die brisant sind. Also wenn man irgendwo Material hat, das vielleicht geheim ist, aber in Skandal aufgedeckt und das man veröffentlichen will, ohne dass man selber das Problem hat, dass die Jungs mit dem Maschinengewehr hinter einem her sind. Dann gibt es Wikileaks, um das zu veröffentlichen. Das ist also für politische Arbeit eine sehr wichtige Seite. Und genau diese Seite hat schon gelitten unter Hausdienst suchen hier in Deutschland wegen Veröffentlichung der australischen Internetsperrlisten. Und auch der neue Gesetzentwurf sieht nicht nur die Sperrung von Kinderpornografie vor, sondern eben genau auch die Sperrung von Seiten, die auflisten, was dann eigentlich alles gesperrt ist.
Schweren kommt da in der Tat hinzu, dass die Liste nicht offengelegt wird. Also dass man gar nicht nachsehen kann, ob da nur Kinderpornoseiten drauf sind oder ob da Seiten drauf sind, die man da so nicht vermuten würde. Und wo es durchaus andere Gründe dafür hat. Und genau die Offenlegung dieser Seiten ist etwas, was explizit, korrigiere mich, was ich da falsch liege, durch das Gesetz auch gedeckt ist, dass das nicht passieren darf.
Die sollen geheim sein, ja.
Na klar, weil so eine Liste, wenn die öffentlich werden würde, würde ja auch heißen, dass du quasi einen Einkaufszettel online stellst.
Genau, das ist natürlich die Befürchtung.
Das gleichzeitig absurd ist, weil es vor Augen führt, dass die sich wohl gewahr sind, dass Leute auch auf diese Seiten kommen, trotz dieses Filters.
Beispiel Australien. Ich denke, das ist wichtig zu erwähnen. Das zeigt deutlich, dass das, worüber wir hier reden, nicht bloß Befürchtungen sind, die nie eintreten werden, sondern nachdem die Sperrliste veröffentlicht wurde aus Australien, hat sich genau gezeigt, dass auch solche Seiten gefiltert wurden, die über Sperren diskutieren. Das heißt, wo sich politisch mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt wird. Und das ist natürlich auch eine sehr große Befürchtung, die hier im Raume steht. Die Internetsperren werden ja vom BKA quasi im Alleingang betrieben. Das heißt, das BKA entscheidet, was gesperrt wird. Und das BKA ist auch, wenn ich das richtig sehe, die Stelle, wo man sich darüber beschwert, wenn etwas gesperrt wird. Und da ist natürlich jegliche demokratische Kontrolle, jeglicher Gewaltenausgleich. Wir haben ja ein System der Gewaltenteilung in unserem Land.
Also, dass z.B. Journalisten kommen, sich die Seite zeigen lassen und wissen wollen, was da genau drauf steht, so was geht da nicht. Das geht da nicht. Dann lassen wir uns noch mal ganz kurz zu diesem eigentlichen Gesetzentwurf zurückkommen, der jetzt folgendes beinhaltet. Also, das BKA hat wie gesagt diese Liste. Die schreiben die Provider an, heißen sie 1 und 1, heißen sie ARKU, heißen sie wie sie eben auch heißen mögen. Die sperren diese Dinger weg. Dann surft man über den Browser dahin, bekommt ein Stoppschild zu sehen, wo drauf steht, sie sehen eine Seite mit gesperrtem Inhalt. Und diese Information, dass ich dahin gesurft bin, die IP-Adresse wird gespeichert und weitergegeben, bedeutet ja, dass ich mich dann irgendwie zumindest verdächtig mache. Habe ich dann gleich eine Hausdurchsuchung, wenn ich eine Mail bekomme mit irgendeinem Link, den ich kenne und anklicke?
Im schlimmsten Falle ja. Diese IP-Adressen sollen ja verwendet werden, um Verdachtsmomente zu gewinnen. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo man da auftaucht auf der Liste, ist man verdächtig. Dann muss weiter ermittelt werden. Eine Möglichkeit der weiteren Ermittlung, wenn andere Mittel aussichtslos sind, ist die Hausdurchsuchung. Das ist natürlich das, was jedem bühnen kann. Wie jeder weiß, der schon mal auf ein Rick Estley-Video versehentlich geklickt hat, ist es sehr einfach, jemanden dazu zu bringen, auf eine URL zu klicken. Frau von der Leyen wurde bestimmt noch nicht geregrollt. Die kennt das Problem gar nicht, das Phänomen gar nicht. Da ist ein großes Problem zu sehen. Das ist auch ein Beispiel dafür, wie wir eigentlich systematisch belogen wurden in der Diskussion. Vor drei Monaten hieß es noch nein und natürlich werden diese Daten nicht erhoben. Das soll ja nur zu Abschreckungszwecken dienen. Das ist uns völlig klar, dass da was passieren kann. Am Tag, nachdem die Gesetzesvorlage da war, ging auch da schon die Diskussion los, wo dann alle Beteiligten zurückgerudert sind und mehr oder weniger verklausuliert gesagt haben, na ja, aber eigentlich können wir die Daten doch erheben.
Wenn die Daten doch da sind, dann kann man sie doch nutzen. Wäre ja schlimm, wenn man das nicht täte.
Was genau immer die Argumentation ist. Du warst bei der Maut ja auch.
Also unter dem Deckmantel der Verhinderung, der Verbreitung von Kinderpornografie, wird hier eigentlich ein Werkzeug geschaffen, um das Netz in irgendeiner Form zu kontrollieren und zu zensieren. Und es gibt keine Möglichkeit, da einzugreifen, weil die Liste der Sperrseiten nicht öffentlich ist, weil die beim BKA liegt. Damit sind wir beim eigentlichen Thema dieser Sendung. Wir reden nämlich heute auch über Entscheidungen aus der Politik, die kommen, also Leute, die entscheiden zum Beispiel über das Internet, obwohl sie so richtig gar nicht davon Ahnung haben, was sich immer wieder zeigt, wenn sie dann zurückrudern oder aber sagen, so war das eigentlich gar nicht gemeint. Beziehungsweise wenn es heißt, es werden keine Daten gespeichert, dann sagt Frau von der Leyen, naja, das Gesetz lässt aber grundsätzlich offen, dass Spuren doch verfolgt werden können. Das heißt, die Daten werden natürlich doch weitergegeben. Und wir würden gerne von euch wissen, unter unserer Telefonnummer 0331 70 97 110, was haltet ihr eigentlich davon, dass demnächst das Internet zensiert wird? Was würde das für euch bedeuten? Wenn diese Sperre übrigens auch eingerichtet wird, würdet ihr die aus Prinzip schon umgehen, alleine nur ums zu machen? Und wie geht ihr damit um? Das wäre interessant zu erfahren. 0331 70 97 110, das ist die Frage. Und was wir hier auch noch diskutieren können, deswegen ist es sehr schön, dass Nibla und Andreas vom CCC auch hier sind, ist die Frage, dass es offenbar viel mehr Information zu diesem Thema gibt, als eigentlich in den Medien transportiert wird. Also weil du siehst, ein Politiker, der sagt, wir gehen gegen Kinderpornografie vor, wir sperren das Netz, und die halbe Welt sagt, ja prima. Wir haben gerade ganz kurz angesprochen, welche Kritikpunkte es dabei gibt. Das heißt, es müsste eigentlich viel mehr Information zum Thema zugänglich gemacht werden. Aber wie kann man das machen? Was habt ihr denn dafür Ideen? Und was kann der CCC da tun?
Was wir tun können, ist zum einen darauf hinweisen, wie das ganze technisch funktioniert, wie man sich dagegen sozusagen schützen kann. Und zum anderen sich darum kümmern, dass eben diese Listen nicht geheim bleiben.
Ja, ich sehe da auch eine Außenkommunikation als sehr großes Problem. Also ich habe ja auch zu dem Thema das eine oder andere Interview gegeben. Und ich habe ja gerade erläutert, dass unser Hauptkritikpunkt ist, nicht, dass wir wollen, dass Leute sich Kinderpornos angucken dürfen, sondern dass die Art und Weise, die da passiert, nicht verfassungskonform ist. Und wenn man diese Erklärung, also irgendwo im Mikrofon sagt, dann schneiden die da genau den Satz raus, Sperren sind nicht wirksam.
Und das Problem ist ja, das ist nicht in ein, zwei, drei Sätzen erklärt.
Wir haben ja zwei Stunden Zeit.
Aber drum ist es eben nicht in der größeren Presse, diese Argumentation. Also das ist einfach was, was man erklären muss, wo man viel Text drauf verschwendet und es liest keiner.
Weil im Moment spaltet sich so ein bisschen die, ich sag mal so die normale, ich gucke Nachrichten, lese Zeitungenwelt in die Blogosphere, also Leute, die wirklich sich tiefer in die Materie begeben, die lange Artikel schreiben und auch Leute, die das wiederum lesen, um es weiter zu verbreiten. Also diese beiden Seiten gibt es da. Und immer wenn auch ich oder ihr sicher auch angesprochen werdet auf das Thema mit dem Argument, das ist doch aber gar nicht so schlimm und ich hab ja eigentlich auch gar nichts zu verbergen, dann fängst du an zu überlegen, ok, dann müssten wir eigentlich bei der Uresuppe anfangen, um zu erklären, worum es hier eigentlich geht. Und vielleicht ist auch das der Punkt in dieser Sendung, wo wir das vielleicht noch mal darlegen können, was hier eigentlich geplant wird. Also noch mal unter welchem, unter dem Deckmantel, der Verhinderung der Verbreitung von Kinderpornografie, was hier eigentlich gerade für einen Daten- und Bürokratiemonster auf uns zurollt. Es soll ja über eine Sperrung der DNS, über eine DNS-Sperrung funktionieren, diese Sperre der Internetseiten.
Das ist jetzt so nicht genau beschrieben.
Das Gesetz lässt das offen. Es gibt so drei grundsätzliche Technologien, die im Raum stehen. Das eine ist die DNS-Sperre. Wir werden sicherlich gleich noch mal alles ausführlich erläutern.
Wir können es ja schon mal anreißen so ein bisschen.
Na gut, dann hole ich schon mal aus. Also DNS, der Domain Name Service, ist der Dienst im Internet, der einen Namen wie zum Beispiel fritz.de, www.fritz.de, nimmt und nachguckt, unter welcher IP-Adresse, also quasi der Telefonnummer im Internet, dieser Dienst erreichbar ist. Wenn man auf so eine Seite surft und bei seinem Browser die URL eingibt, ist das DNS im Hintergrund im Spiel, um rauszufinden, wo der Browser sich jetzt hin verbinden muss. Und was da passiert? Normalerweise, also für die verschiedenen Bestandteile dieses Namens, gibt es verschiedene Server, die zuständig sind. Also es gibt da für.de für Deutschland einen, der weiß, wer fritz.de kennt. Und da kann man also hingehen zu dem Server für.de, fragt ihn, wo steht denn fritz.de, und dann geht man zu fritz.de und fragt, wo ist denn www.fritz.de und bekommt eine Antwort. Ganz grob. Und das macht mein Rechner aber nicht selber, sondern das macht ein sogenannter forwarding-nameserver oder caching-nameserver, den ich von meinem Provider bekomme. Das heißt, wenn ich mich bei meinem Provider einwähle, bekomme ich die IP-Adresse eines solchen Nameservers gesagt und den frage ich. Und der läuft dann für mich los zu den anderen Servern, die im Internet stehen, um den Namen aufzulösen. Wo der Filteransatz jetzt angreift, ist bei genau diesem Forwarding Name Server. Da wird also konfiguriert, dass für bestimmte Namensanfragen eine andere Antwort zurückgeliefert werden soll.
Also www.schweinkram.de, dann merkt er sich das und schickt eine andere Anfrage zurück.
Genau, dann schickt er die Antwort zurück mit der IP-Adresse von der Stop-Seite.
Jetzt heißt es ja von Seiten der Gesetzgebung, also vom Bundesfamilienministerium, vom Bundesinnenministerium und vom Bundeskriminalamt, dass diese Sperren nur für wirkliche Profis und Cracks zu umgehen sind. Parallel dazu taucht gerade, also kursiert gerade durch jedes zweite Weblog ein Video, wo erklärt wird, wie man innerhalb von 27 Sekunden diese Sperren umgeht. Und es tauchten ja auch schon in Interviews die Formulierung auf, dass Leute, die diese Sperre umgehen, eigentlich potenziell schon Kinderpornografie suchen würden.
Und sie nennt dabei 20%?
Also die 20% der Internet-User, die wissen, was in einem Nameserver ist, ich glaube ja, es sind mehr, die sind alle pädophil, wenn man unserer Familienministerin glaubt. Was natürlich total absurd ist. Die Argumentation, die da gebracht wird, ist eigentlich auch einer Ministerin nicht würdig. Aber zurück zu unserem Nameserver. Die Umgehung ist relativ einfach. Man sucht sich einfach einen anderen Forwarding-Nameserver. Da gibt es Listen im Netz. Einfach nach Open Nameserver googeln, da findet man Hunderte. Die trägt man ein. Windows, Netzwerkstack klicken, dann IP-Adresskonfiguration, manuell und den Nameserver.
Und dann hat man das umgangen.
Die Anleitung ist in 27 Sekunden für jeden Volllein, das einfach nachmachen und dann ist das geklärt.
Das wird überhaupt gar nicht helfen gegen jemanden, der auch nur für 5 Minuten nachdenkt und sich bemüht, an diese Seiten ranzukommen. Ich habe ein relativ gutes Argument dafür gehört von einem Psychologen, der gesagt hat, dass es tatsächlich Pädophile gibt, die dann irgendwann anfangen, Kinder zu vergewaltigen. Das ist eine Realität, mit der wir klarkommen müssen, gegen die wir etwas tun können. Und der hat gesagt, dass wenn Leute diese Seiten hinterherklicken, quasi ihrem Trieb nachgeben, die in so einer Art Rauschzustand sind und nicht mehr wirklich sich dessen bewusst sind, was sie da eigentlich tun. Und dass dieses Stoppschild sie da durchaus mal rausreißen kann und sagen kann, reflektier doch mal, was tust du hier eigentlich gerade und wo wird das hinführen. Es ist ein Argument dafür.
Das Problem ist, so ein Stoppschild im Straßenverkehr ist auch nur, dass man an der Ampel oder an der Stelle, wo dieses Stoppschild steht, anhält, links, rechts guckt und dann weiterfährt.
Also das wird das nicht verhindern, dass es jemand tut. Vielleicht hat es eine psychologische Wirkung und ist aber auf jeden Fall von der Priorität her, würde ich sagen, der der aktiven Strafverfolgung nachgeordnet. Und da haben wir ja positive Beispiele. Das, was sehr bekannt geworden ist, ist ein Bild von auch einem Deutschen, der sich in Thailand hat fotografieren lassen mit minderjährigen Mädels, wo das Gesicht verzerrt war, wo dann das BKA mit Photoshop das Gesicht entzerrt hat und den Mann identifiziert hat, sodass das ist wichtig, wirklich an die Täter ranzukommen, die da aktiv sind. Und die psychologische Betreuung von Pädophilen, das ist etwas, was auch wichtig ist und was aber meines Erachtens später kommt und was vor allen Dingen die Schwere des Grundrechtseingriffs an der Stelle nicht rechtfertigt. Das wäre was anderes, wenn da vielleicht tatsächlich der Link drunter wäre mit irgendwie, wenn du es dir trotzdem angucken willst, dann klick da drauf, aber wir haben dich gewarnt. Dann würden diese Bedenken wegfallen. Dann wäre dieser psychologische Effekt da, aber die Bedenken und die Missbrauchsmöglichkeit für ein solches Zensurinstrument, die würde wegfallen.
Habe ich dich da jetzt richtig verstanden, dass diese Sperre, die jetzt gerade installiert wird, dass die eigentlich wirkungslos ist?
Die ist für jemanden, der nicht zufällig klickt, sondern gezielt klickt, wirkungslos.
Okay, und jetzt kommt die Frage nochmal, warum installieren Sie dieses Sperrding trotzdem unter der Überschrift, wir verhindern Kinderpornografie?
Weil es ein Anfang ist, so eine Maßnahme einzuführen und diese dann technisch zu erweitern, dass sie wirkungsvoller wird mit anderen Technologien, die nicht so einfach zu erledigen sind. Das wäre dann so der nächste Schritt und irgendwo muss man anfangen.
Die griechische Salamitaktik. Natürlich hilft es auch, wenn man, also lass uns beim Wikileaks-Beispiel bleiben, es wird ein brisantes Dokument veröffentlicht über wen auch immer in diesem Staat. Sagen wir irgendjemand, der hochrangig ist, Dreck am Stecken hat und in der Lage ist, solche Mechanismen zu benutzen, um das zu tarnen. Da ist dann im Zweifelsfall für den einen Tag, wo das Ding durch die Presse geht, der Server erstmal nicht erreichbar. Und dann gibt es da auch weniger Leute, die das wahrnehmen. Das kann, wenn man sich moderne, ich sag jetzt mal informationelle Kriegsführung, andere Leute sagen dazu PR-Arbeit anguckt, dann ist den Zugang zu Quellen auch nur einen Tag zu verhindern. Schon etwas, was weiterhilft in einer solchen Debatte. Und auch da sind DNS-Sperren sozusagen schon Mittel. Natürlich lassen sie sich umgehen, aber die 80% der Leute, die keine Kinderpornos klicken oder sagen wir mal eher 99%, die haben natürlich keine Umgehung für das DNS installiert. Und wenn dann politisch brisante Dokumente auftauchen, dann sehen sie die halt nicht. Dann sind sie sich auch nicht dessen bewusst, dass da gerade was passiert.
Vor allem sieht man über das Logging der IP-Adressen, wer sich sehr früh für diese Dokumente interessiert.
Aber es kommt ein Gesetz auf uns zu, was sehr viele große bunte Überschriften trägt. Kaum jemand guckt dahinter und fragt wirklich nach. Das Chaosradio auf Ritz wird versuchen, in dieser und auch in vielen anderen Sendungen genau das zu umgehen. Und wir wollen auch euch natürlich fragen, was ihr davon haltet, dass dieses Gesetz da möglicherweise auf uns zukommt. Noch hat der Bundestag es nicht durchgewunken, aber so wie im Moment die allgemeine Zustimmung ist, ist das zumindest für meine Empfindung eigentlich nur der Frage der Zeit, bis es soweit wird. Und wir wollen von euch wissen, was haltet ihr denn davon? 0331 70 97 110. Der erste am Telefon ist Michael. Einen schönen guten Abend, Michael. Hallo?
Hallo?
Ach, am Start. Hallo Michael, grüß dich. Tachchen, was hältst du denn davon, dass dieses Sperrgesetz auf uns zurollt?
Ich habe eine Ausbildung zum Informatiker gemacht und wir haben schon im ersten Lehrjahr komplett die ganze Palette von Anonymisierungstools von Proxy-Servern oder anonymen DNS-Servern durchgemacht und die Sperre ist meines Erachtens absolut wirkungslos. Also wie schon vorhin im Beitrag gesagt, jemand, der sich damit fünf Minuten auseinandersetzt, der hat da eigentlich komplette Narrenfreiheit, irgendwelche Seiten anzusurfen, die im Vorfeld irgendwie durch DNS-Server gesperrt wurden.
Das heißt also, wenn ihr euch das im ersten Jahr angeschaut habt, dass das eine durchaus realistische Handwerkszeug ist, sich im Internet so zu bewegen, dass einen soviel da nicht interessieren?
Natürlich auch ein Laie, der, sag ich mal, bei Google einen eingibt, anonym der DNS-Server und sich da irgendein Workaround raussucht, der kann innerhalb von paar Minuten sofort auf die Seiten zugreifen, die vorher von seinem Provider gesperrt wurden.
Was ist denn, wenn du sagst, du hältst nichts von diesem Gesetz und du hältst es auch aufgrund deines Fachwissens für wirkungslos, also die technische Umsetzung des Ganzen, was kannst du denn, oder was würdest du denn als Michael machen, um deine Meinung da kundzutun? Weil wir haben ja vorhin auch schon festgestellt, dass eigentlich viel zu wenig Information über die Hintergründe und die zweite oder dritte Salamischeibe kursieren.
Also zum einen, man müsste auf jeden Fall mehr Informationen in der Presse darbieten. Erstens Zeitungen. Man bietet im Endeffekt nur Infostar, wo drinnen steht, gut, Kinderpornografie sperren, ja, sofort. Aber dass man im Hintergrund mal ein bisschen überlegt, um was es da überhaupt geht, das wird überhaupt nicht gesagt. Der normale Bürger wird komplett alleine gelassen und gar nicht weiter groß informiert. Die vorher Information ist einfach gut, Kinderpornografie sperren, aber wie, wird weiter nicht groß diskutiert.
Aber ums jetzt, also ich will dich da jetzt nicht irgendwie in die Enge treiben, aber ums nochmal zu fragen, du hast eben gesagt, die Medien oder die Zeitungen müssten darüber mehr berichten. Die Zeitungen sagen ja, okay, wir machen diese riesen Schlagzeile und es verkauft sich. Was kannst du denn jetzt machen, wenn du sagst, es nervt mich, dass da zu wenig Information noch in den Zeitungen ist? Was würdest du tun?
Also ich persönlich würde auch mal im Betrag sehen, mal einen guten Leserbrief zu schreiben. Ich denke mal, wenn mehrere Leute Leserbriefe schreiben und wenn sich da mehr zusammentun, so wie damals bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, dann kann man da auch viel mehr bewegen.
Das betrifft ja die Journalisten auch selbst. Also die werden ja in ihrer Recherche dadurch auch beeinflusst.
Also das Hauptproblem ist auch, dass ich denke mal, die Information selbst, dass bei vielen das noch nicht richtig angekommen ist. Es sind halt eben nur kleine Brocken hingeworfen worden, Pornografie mit Kindern und mehr auch eigentlich nicht.
Vor zehn Jahren war es Terrorbekämpfung. Genau, so sieht es aus.
Siehe komplett genauso.
Würdest du als Internet-Auskenner, sag ich es mal ganz salopp, aus Prinzip schon allein aus sportlichem Ehrgeiz diese Sperre umgehen?
Auf gar keinen Fall eigentlich nicht. Also ich meine, mich interessieren solche Seiten überhaupt nicht. Und ich meine, man kennt es von Wikileaks, als damals dieses Dokument rauskam von dieser australischen Sperrgeschichte, war die Seite sofort am nächsten Tag down. Und ich meine, bei solchen Sachen ist es im Endeffekt genau das gleiche Spiel. Also es ist schwierig.
Also Leserbriefe schreiben, wenn euch was nicht passt, entweder zum Beispiel an Fritz, da brauchst du auch Leserbriefe, einfach eine Mail schreiben oder einfach hier im Blue Moon anrufen, denn das ist die Chance, eure Meinung zu sagen. 0331 70 97 110 Wir haben noch Zeit bis Mitternacht, um über die anstehende Sperre vom Internet zu reden. Der Gesetzentwurf ist durch. Der Bundesrat muss jetzt noch zustimmen und der Bundestag. Und dann geht es möglicherweise ab. In diesem Wahlkampf ein sehr heikles Thema. Wir reden gleich weiter mit euch. Wir machen jetzt erst mal Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr. Und Micha, dir vielen Dank für den Anruf.
Manchmal kommt neue Musik nicht aus den Charts, sondern genau dahin, wo ihr wohnt. Die Fritz-DJs machen Party in den besten Clubs vorne hier und in der Gegend. Morgen Abend im Bebel in Cottbus. Und in welche Clubs sie noch kommen? Die Fritz-DJs. Nur in den besten Clubs von hier und in der Gegend.
2 nach halb 11.
Fritz-Info.
Mit Kajtan Dirlich.
In Afghanistan ist ein deutscher Soldat getötet worden. Laut Bundeswehr geriet er am Abend in der Nähe der Stadt Kunduz mit seiner Patrouille in einen Hinterhalt. Vier weitere Soldaten wurden dabei leicht verletzt. Erst am Morgen waren fünf Bundeswehrsoldaten ganz in der Nähe bei einem Selbstmordanschlag leicht verletzt worden. Studiengebühren an deutschen Hochschulen bleiben erlaubt. Das Bundesverwaltungsgericht in Leipzig hat die Klage einer jungen Frau aus Paderborn abgewiesen. Die Frau hat sich gegen die Semestergebühren in Nordrhein-Westfalen von 500 Euro gewährt. Die Bundesrichter urteilten, dass die Gebühr zwar eine Belastung sei, allerdings sei die Hürde nicht unüberwindbar, hieß es. Der Anwalt der Klägerin überlegt nun, vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht zu ziehen. Berlins Datenschutzbeauftragter Dix hat junge Leute davor gewarnt, zu viele persönliche Infos ins Internet zu stellen. Besonders bei sozialen Netzwerken wie Facebook oder Studi4Z rät er zur Vorsicht. Nutzer sollten nicht ungeschützt private Daten und Bilder online stellen, das würde den Datenmissbrauch erleichtern. In der Fußball-Champions League laufen die letzten Minuten des zweiten Halbfinalspiels. Im rheinbritischen Duell führt immer noch Manchester United gegen Arsenal London mit 1 zu 0. Die Temperaturen in Wittenberge, da sind es 14 Grad, Potsdam und Cottbus 15, Frankfurt, Neuropin und Angermünde 16 Grad und in Berlin derzeit 15 Grad. Heute Nacht gibt es nur wenige Wolken und es ist meistens trocken. Die Temperaturen gehen bis auf 6 Grad runter. Morgen ist es oft heiter, besonders an der Elbe. Es gibt im Tagesfall auch ein bisschen Regen und auch manchmal ein paar Gewitter, sonst bleibt es trocken bei bis zu 25 Grad. Bitte Vorsicht auf der A2 Berlin Richtung Magdeburg zwischen Dreieck Werder und Lenin. Da gibt es eine Baustelle, dadurch sind da zwei Spuren gesperrt, nämlich die linke und die mittlere Spur. A10, nördlicher Berliner Ring, Richtung Dreieck Haveland, zwischen Kreuz Oranienburg und Obergrämer. Da liegen Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn, genau gesagt ein totes Reh. Auch da vorsichtig fahren. Und A15, Dreieck Spreewald Richtung Übergang Forst zwischen Roggosen und Forst. Da brennt ein Fahrzeug, rechnet dort bitte mit Behinderung. Euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Blum, die zwei Sprechstunden.
Chaosradio auf Fritz, herzlich willkommen kurz nach halb elf. Wir reden heute über das geplante Gesetz zur Sperre von bestimmten Internetseiten. Hauptargument, es geht um Kinderpornografie, um die zu verhindern. Die Kritiker sagen, es geht gar nicht um Kinderpornografie. Das lässt sich viel besser anders verhindern. Sonst geht es darum, ein Werkzeug zu installieren, um das Netz zu zensieren. Was haltet ihr davon? 0331 70 97 110. Erubjörn und er im Chaosradio am Donnerstagabend auf Fritz für die Statistiker. Wir sind in der Serie 145. Wir reden heute wieder mal über die geplante Sperre von Internetseiten. Im Januar haben wir darüber schon mal gesprochen. Da war es eigentlich eher eine theoretische und hypothetische Diskussion über das, was kommen kann. Seit letzter Woche Mittwoch ist es klar, der Gesetzentwurf ist durch und dieses Gesetz zur Sperrung von bestimmten Internetseiten rollt auf uns zu. Es gibt jede Menge Kritik daran. Was können wir alle dagegen tun, dass Politiker über Sachen entscheiden, von denen sie eigentlich keine Ahnung haben? Die Chaos Computer Club, Leute nennen die auch gerne mal die Internetausdrucker. Wir haben zwei Internetchecker hier, nicht Internetausdrucker, sondern Internetchecker. Nämlich Andreas und Nibbler vom CCC. Tagchen noch mal.
Tagchen.
Und ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110, um zu sagen, wie ihr euch persönlich dazu verhaltet, was ihr machen könnt, um eurer Meinung Luft zu machen und was ihr von diesem geplanten Zensurmonster haltet. Der nächste Anruf kommt aus Bremen von Jan. Moin, Jan.
Hallo.
Moin. Was hältst du von dem Bürokratenmonster, was er auf uns zurollt?
Ja, absolut gar nichts. Also für mich ist das irgendwie eine Scheinmaßnahme, weil so wird keinem Kind geholfen, dass irgendwie missbraucht wurde und so kommt man auch an die Täter nicht ran. Und ich verstehe eigentlich überhaupt nicht, was das Ganze soll. Weil eigentlich ist doch weltweit Konsens, dass Kinderpornografie illegal ist. Also mir fällt ad hoc jetzt kein Land ein, wo man sagen könnte, hey, ich hoste hier mal auf so einem Server irgendwelches Kinderporn und Zeug und lasse mir dafür Geld überweisen. Da fällt mir kein einziges Land ein. Und an der Stelle frage ich mich, was soll dann so eine Scheuklappen-Zensur? Da kann man doch eigentlich, wenn man so was findet, effektiver gegen vorgehen, indem man sich an die Strafvollzugsbehörden des jeweiligen Landes wendet und dann darüber den Hoster bzw. im Endeffekt vielleicht auch mal die Täter ausfindig macht und dementsprechend wirklich was tut.
Sie sagen, dass ein großer Teil der Seiten, die in den ausländischen Zensurlisten, die geleakt sind, in Deutschland gehostet wird. Also wenn man das ernst meinen würde, dann würde man sich erstmal in die Richtung bewegen und mal gucken.
Aber die wirklich spannende Frage ist, nachdem wir jetzt ja doch zu dem Schluss gekommen sind und ich sehe keine Argumente dagegen, dass die Bekämpfung der Kinderpornografie nicht das eigentliche Ziel ist. Was ist dann das eigentliche Ziel?
Was denkst du denn, Jan?
Ja, für mich ist das eine Zensurmaßnahme einfach. Ich meine, dass es in weiten Teilen wirkungslos ist und dass irgendwie sogar meine Mutter in der Lage ist, das zu umgehen, obwohl die jetzt, ich würde jetzt für den Otto Normal Internetnutzer erzählen. Für mich ist das einfach irgendwo der sinnlose und irgendwo planlose Versuch von Politikern, die von der Materie auch irgendwie keinerlei Ahnung haben, irgendwo eine Zensurmaßinfrastruktur zu erschaffen.
Aber was glaubst du denn, warum das jetzt mit so einer Vehemenz vorgetrieben wird?
Ja, Wahl, nicht? Da muss man nochmal vorlegen.
Super Wahlthema.
Wäre jetzt meine Meinung.
Und da gibt es auch Argumente für, denn die Provider, die vor der Schaffung einer gesetzlichen Grundlage unterschrieben haben, die haben das ja auch nicht alle unbedingt freiwillig getan. Denn die Techniker bei den großen Providern haben ihren Chefs auch erzählt, dass das total sinnlos ist. Und nun muss man aber wissen, dass ein gewisser Herr Riesenhuber, der ist ja nicht sogar CSU, CDU, der sitzt im Aufsichtsrat von Kabel Deutschland und sitzt im Vorstand von Vodafone.
War der nicht mal Wirtschaftsminister?
Der war mal Wirtschaftsminister. Und der steht auch auf Platz 2 der Landesliste, davon habe ich auch schon wieder vergessen. Der hat auf jeden Fall auch ein Interesse daran, dass die nächste Regierung eine CDU-Regierung wird. Und hat an der Stelle ganz knallhart ein Wahlkampfmanöver gefördert.
Ist diese ganzen technischen Maßnahmen, die da jetzt eingeführt werden, ist das auch irgendwie so ein wirtschaftlicher Aspekt? Also gibt es da, ich frage mal jetzt ganz frech, gibt es da von Seiten der Hardware- Softwarehersteller gibt es da Geld zu verdienen? Wird da ein Markt gewittert?
Das auf jeden Fall.
Ja, aber keine deutschen Hersteller.
Also gibt es auch von der Seite ein großes Interesse daran, sowas zu installieren?
Ein mittelgroßes. Die Firma Cisco stellt da Module her, mit denen man Deep Packet Inspection machen kann. Da kommen wir vielleicht nachher noch mal drauf zurück. Ich erinnere mich dran, dass ich erkläre, was das ist.
Ich schreibe es mir jetzt auf.
Deep Packet Inspection, ganz wichtig.
Deep Packet Inspection geht aber schon weiter als eine einfache DNS-Maßnahme.
Das geht schon deutlich weiter, das ist richtig. Da wird tatsächlich in die Verbindung eingegriffen. Das heißt, da wird zugehört, was da auf der Verbindung gesprochen wird.
Also für mich ist das dann an der Stelle ein Eingriff ins Fernmeld, wie man es nennen mag.
Das ist Dual-Use-Hardware. Also ein ISP kann das generell zur Paketklassifizierung einsetzen und kann sich beispielsweise darum kümmern, dass sein Voice-over-IP-Traffic ungehindert durch kann und priorisiert wird. Also für die Provider durchaus nicht nur das Interesse da, eine rechtliche Regelung durchzusetzen, sondern die haben dann auch Hardware, mit denen sie die Last auf den Netz besser verteilen können und so weiter. Und das ist der Grund, warum sich jetzt ein ISP erstmal so nicht dagegen sträuben wird, wenn eventuell schon, wir haben das bei der TKÖV gesehen, in einem zweiten Schritt in Aussicht gestellt werden könnte, dass Provider das zum Teil vom Staat finanziert bekommen.
Nebla, kannst du das nochmal auf Deutsch erklären?
Also dass ein Internet-Service-Provider diese Infrastruktur bei sich deployen kann, also das Netz einbauen, und da durchaus vom Staat finanzielle Unterstützung kriegt und damit eben nicht nur Filtermaßnahmen durchsetzen kann, sondern auch durchsetzen kann, dass die Qualität dir das Internet gefühlt hat. Also dass man, wenn man über das Internet telefoniert, dass das priorisiert wird.
Aber um die Frage abschließend zu beantworten, wir haben das durchaus schon gesehen, dass Hardware-Hersteller ein Interesse an diversen Sicherheitsthemen haben. Ich erwähne bloß das Stichwort EPAS, das also wirklich ganz eindeutig von den entsprechenden Herstellern gepusht wurde. Bei der Gesundheitskarte ist es nichts anderes. In dem Fall ist davon ausnahmsweise mal nichts zu spüren, das sind nicht die Hersteller.
Also Jan, um nochmal zu dir zurückzukommen, du hast ja auch gesagt, du hältst überhaupt nichts von diesem Gesetz und siehst ja eigentlich eine Zensurmaßnahme auf uns zu rollen. Was kannst du denn, also Jan aus Bremen, Kraft deiner eigenen Stimme und deiner Meinung, was kannst du denn machen, um deine Meinung da kundzutun, wenn offensichtlich zu wenig Informationen darüber kursieren und die Politiker über Sachen entscheiden, von denen sie nicht so richtig Ahnung haben?
Das erste, was man machen kann, ist natürlich erstmal mit allen sprechen, die man sonst so kennt. Also Freunde, Bekannte.
Redet ihr da im Freundeskreis? Redest du mit deinen Kumpels drüber? Oder mit deinem Familie? Wie ist denn da die gängige Meinung?
Einen Open-DNS-Server zu finden und bei sich persönlich einzutragen, ist jetzt nicht so die große Hürde, nur das löst natürlich nicht das Problem an sich. Weil irgendwann heißt es dann, ja gut, DNS-Maßnahme ist nicht wirksam, brauchen wir jetzt wirklich die Packet-Inspection und ähnliches. Und dann geht das halt einen Schritt weiter. Das ist dann irgendwann eine Lawine. Und das ist dann, wenn es erst mal am Rollen ist, nicht mehr so einfach aufzuhalten. Man muss halt an der Stelle jetzt auch, denke ich mal, als mündiger Bürger durchaus aktiv werden. Also für mich steht jetzt schon fest, wer diesen Schwachsinn unterstützt, den werde ich definitiv nicht wählen.
Zum Beispiel. Aber eine Situation, die wir alle kennen, die wir uns mit dem Thema ein kleines bisschen mehr oder weniger beschäftigen, ist, dass du in die Diskussion mit Leuten kommst, mit Freunden, Familie, wer auch immer, alles gerade da ist. Und sie sagen so, ich finde das ja eigentlich gut. Und dann fängst du an mit Argumenten. Ich habe ja nichts zu verbergen. Ich fange an mit Argumenten zusammen. Kennst du so eine Diskussion auch, Jan?
Ja, natürlich. Wie läuft das?
Mit welchen Argumenten versuchst du das zu belegen?
Ja, gerade beim Totschlag-Argument Kinderpornografie. Ich meine, keiner ist dafür. Also ich würde zumindest keinen kennen. Aber es ist halt einfach mal an der Sache vorbei. Und das kann man ja durchaus plausibel darlegen.
Zum Beispiel auch in dieser Sendung, die sehr viele Leute hören. Ihr könnt sie auch natürlich im Stream hören oder als Podcast chaosradio.ccc.de. Da steht ihr dann auch morgen oft mit drauf. Danke, Jan, für den Anruf, auf jeden Fall.
Tschüss.
Und Andreas, eigentlich wollten wir später dazu kommen, aber jetzt viermal hintereinander, Deep Packet Inspection, vielleicht sollten wir das doch ganz kurz erklären und dann machen wir mal mit Ron und mit Fidel und mit Patrick und mit vielen anderen auch noch weiter, die am Telefon warten.
Okay, Deep Packet Inspection. Die DNS-Filter haben einen ganz entscheidenden Nachteil. Man kann nur einen Rechner, also sozusagen einen Namen eines Rechners komplett abschalten. Und da sind nicht nur die Webseiten, die darauf liegen, betroffen, sondern auch alle anderen Dienste zum einen. Und zum zweiten ist es so, dass auch die gesamte Webseite abgeschaltet wird, nicht nur ein Teil davon. Und nun kann es ja mal passieren, das sagen wir auf der Wikipedia, ist ja passiert in Großbritannien. Da gab es einen Cover der Band Scorpions.
Das war das Album Virgin Killer, wo ein Foto von einem nackten Mädchen drauf ist. Die Platte ist übrigens 73 oder 72 erschienen, und es hat 30 Jahre lang keinen interessiert.
Genau. Und da hat irgendjemand Anzeige gestellt, und daraufhin wurde das gesperrt. Und nun kann man natürlich nicht die komplette Wikipedia sperren. Das würden wirklich alle merken, auf die Barrikaden gehen.
Oh, es gibt aber glaube ich Leute, die wollen sowas.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Und was die Packet-Inspection jetzt macht, ist, in die Pakete, die im Internet laufen, reinzugucken, daraus die Verbindung wieder herzustellen und dazu analysieren, was genau auf dieser Webseite wurde eigentlich abgerufen. Und das erlaubt also die gezielte Sperrung von bestimmten URLs, nicht nur von ganzen Sites.
Das heißt, ich kann nicht eine komplette Webseite wegklicken, sondern ich kann einen bestimmten Aspekt, einen bestimmten Teil von der Webseite abschalten?
Genau, das geht natürlich beliebig weiter. Man kann natürlich auch Inhalte modifizieren auf Webseiten. Das ist, wenn man schon einmal dabei ist, dann kann man auch das ausleiten, anderen Content reinmachen und so weiter.
Also zum Beispiel könntest du bei fritz.de dann den Aspekt fritz.de slash die Musik oder fritz.de Infobücher oder so, das könntest du abschalten?
Genau, bzw. die Bücher durch Kinderpornos ersetzen und dann euren Intendanten verhaften lassen.
Oder so Dinge tun wie Werbebanner austauschen durch die Banner der eigenen Werbekunden.
Oh ja, das wird auch schon gemacht. Sehr beliebt.
Okay, aber wir kommen nochmal zurück. Wir nehmen mal Annes in der Zwischenzeit ganz kurz ans Telefon. Hallo Annes, grüß dich. Du hast eine Frage zu dieser Sperre und diesem einfachen Zuumgehen. Wir haben es ja vorhin erwähnt, Frau von der Leyen sagt, die Sperre ist überhaupt nicht einfach zu umgehen, das können nur Profis und in jedem zweiten Weblog steht, ist beschrieben, wie das innerhalb von 27 Sekunden zu machen ist. Und du willst wissen, warum das so einfach ist, oder?
Ja, ich meine, wenn der Start das wirklich machen wollte, also wenn er das wirklich richtig abschalten wollte, dann würde er doch die Sperre halt bisschen härter machen. Dass man nicht in 28 Sekunden durchkommt.
Das ist natürlich eine richtige Überlegung. Da müssen wir uns mal in Richtung China wenden. Uns das Beispiel China angucken. Die versuchen das ja. Und die sind damit mittelmäßig erfolgreich. Sie können es nicht immer komplett unterbinden, dass kommuniziert wird. Aber die haben tatsächlich einen Technologiepark hochgefahren. Da gibt es die Packet-Inspection bis zum Abwinken. Da gibt es automatisierte Trafik-Analyse, die nach Mustern sucht und sagt, hier ist ein neues Muster, das ich noch nicht kenne. Und dann setzt sich händisch jemand hin und guckt sich den Verkehr an. Aber das ist natürlich ein unglaublich großer Aufwand. Man schafft damit auch eine Struktur, die nahezu nicht mehr zu kontrollieren ist. Man muss einen derartigen Aufwand treiben, ein derartiges großes Gebilde bauen, das im Prinzip vom Internet nichts mehr übrig wäre. Das halt darauf fußt, dass jeder mit jedem kommunizieren kann. Sondern man müsste dann schon hingehen und sagen, was sind denn erlaubte Inhalte und was sind verbotene Inhalte. Und dann dürfen nur noch die erlaubten angezeigt werden. Die Content-Industrie möchte das natürlich gern. Die möchte nicht, dass jeder User Sachen ins Netz stellen kann, dass jeder seine eigene Seite hat, sondern die möchte gerne, dass du das kommerzielle Angebot kaufst. Die sind da wahrscheinlich ein großer Freund von. Aber die Antwort ist, es geht einfach nicht komplett zu sperren.
Das ist auch ein Trend, der sich in den letzten Monaten, Jahren gezeigt hat, dass sich das Internet von Internet-Service-Providern zu einem Produkt wird, was sozusagen ein zusammengestellter Inhaltepaket ist und nicht mehr Zugang zu einem Netz.
Also an ist die Antwort auf deine Frage, weil es schlicht und ergreifend nicht geht, so einfach.
Und andere Sache noch, und zwar, wenn jetzt mal der Typ, der ganze Nacht über das Internet hat, wenn der jetzt einfach sagt, hey, ich begegne Kinder-Pornografie. Und dann sagt er einfach, ich stehe jetzt mal durch ganz, ganz viele Seiten und alle Pronoseiten, die ich finde, die lösche ich einfach.
Na, das ist das Problem am Internet, dass es eben keine einzelne Person gibt oder eine einzelne Entität, die darüber bestimmen kann.
Es gibt ja keine Internet-Regierung in dem Fall.
Das ist die Chance am Internet.
Aber es gibt doch bestimmt irgendeinen, in Area 51 eben so einen Hauptrechner, wodurch man das ganze Internet abschalten kann. Von da aus müsste man dann auch...
Muss ich dich nicht enttäuschen. Das ist glücklicherweise nicht so. Also das Internet ist ein sehr...
Es wurde vom amerikanischen Verteidigungsministerium, wenn wir da schon sind, genau dafür entwickelt, auch weiter zu funktionieren, wenn die zentrale Stelle kaputt gemacht wurde.
Aber wie will dann die USA das Internet abschalten, wenn so ein Hackerangriff kommt?
Die können das nicht abschalten.
Die können das bohren, aber sie werden es nicht schaffen.
Okay, also es geht schlicht und ergreifend nicht alles.
Das ist auch der Punkt, weswegen wir sagen, also diese Seiten liegen ja auf Rechnern. Diese Rechner stehen irgendwo und da kann man einfach hingehen mit der Polizei und kann eine Hausdurchsuchung machen, kann die Rechner beschlagnahmen. Das heißt ja immer, die Politiker stellen sich immer gerne hin und sagen, das Internet ist kein rechtsfreier Raum. Also zum einen ist das Internet kein Raum und rechtsfrei ist es schon gar nicht. Da gelten natürlich genau dieselben Gesetze, die außerhalb des Internets auch gelten und sie können da genauso durchgesetzt werden.
Man geht ja nicht darum, irgendwie Seiten zu beschlagnahmen oder Seiten verschwinden zu lassen, sondern die Betreiber dieser Seiten an den Wickel zu kriegen.
Genau, nämlich die, die Verbrechen begangen haben.
So ein Problem kriegt man nur in den Griff, wenn man eben nicht die Symptome bekämpft, sondern wirklich bei den Leuten vorstellig wird klingelt. Du hast da Dinge im Internet veröffentlicht, was irgendwie nicht so okay ist.
Aber wir geben die Frage von Anis mal gleich weiter an Ron aus Berlin namens Ron. Die Frage von Anis ist natürlich absolut berechtigt. Also was kann man machen? Was kann er machen? Was können wir machen? Was kann ich machen? Was kannst du machen?
Wir sind ja nicht in der Regierung, aber ich würde mal einen Gedanken zurückgeben. Ich vermute hinter dieser ganzen Konstellation nämlich einen komplett anderen Grund, warum man da nun so vorgeht. Ich erinnere an den 11. September. Danach kamen Empörungen und man sagte, wir müssen was dagegen tun. Was hat man gemacht? Man hat die Steuern erhöht. Das war das erste, was man gemacht hat. Zigaretten sind teurer geworden, Alkohol ist teurer geworden. Man sucht immer irgendwo einen Vorwand. Ich vermute, jetzt heißt es Kinderpornografie. Was hat der Staat damit für Möglichkeiten? Er hat dann Möglichkeiten, Daten zu sammeln von Bürgern. Er hat damit Möglichkeiten, Gründe zu finden, um z.B. Hausdurchsuchungen durchzuführen, um vielleicht bei der Gelegenheit, Steuereinsatz hier z.B. dingfest zu machen. Ich glaube, dass das alles missbraucht wird von staatlichen Institutionen als Vorwand, um Daten zu sammeln über die Bürger und aus diesen Daten auch Profit zu machen. Beziehungsweise könnte es sein, dass der Staat sagt, wir müssen die Kinder schützen, das ist ja legitim, aber dafür müssen wir finanzielle Mittel aufwenden. Und das geht nur mit Steuererhöhungen. Also ich sehe da so, man tut immer gerne irgendwas im Vordergrund. Es ist ja natürlich keiner gegen keiner Flüpp-Kinderpornografie, das ist klar, aber im Vordergrund sucht der Staat und den hat er natürlich auch damit auf ideale Weise gefunden, mit dieser Thematik. Und wenn ich nun noch weitergehe, ich habe letztens in einer renommierten Zeitung gelesen, da hat jemand die Simpsons nackt bei irgendwelchen sexuellen Aktivitäten gezeigt. Das gilt als Kinderpornografie, das muss man sich mal überlegen. Die Simpsons als Kinderpornografie. Und was ist überhaupt Kinderpornografie? Ist das, wenn ein Mädchen 16 ist oder wenn sie 18 ist? Wo fängt das an, wo hört das auf? Meiner Meinung nach wird das nur missbraucht, hier um Informationen zu sammeln, die sind kostbar. Wir wissen ja auch, dass Google auch Daten sammelt über Bürger, die in einer Straße wohnen. Und dann sagt man zum Beispiel, da werden oft Seiten angeklickt, die sich mit Wirtschaft beschäftigen, verkauft Google die Daten und sagt, macht Leute auch da mal eine Werbetafel hin und werbt für die Wirtschaftswoche zum Beispiel. Das sind Daten und da geht es um Geld und um Macht und es geht um Einfluss und es geht darum, hier gezielt Vorwand zu suchen, um irgendwie dem Bürger eine Steuererhöhung zu verkaufen. Aber mit Sicherheit geht es nicht darum, um da Kinder zu schützen.
Also ist dieses Gesetz, um es zusammenzufassen, aus seiner Sicht hauptsächlich ein weiteres Tool, um Daten zu sammeln?
Ganz genau. Nur. Also nicht nur Daten zu sammeln, sondern um mit die Daten natürlich dann auch dementsprechend zu agieren. Und ich sag ja, ich erinnere mich gut an den 11. September. Jeder war empört, dieser fürchterliche Terroranschlag. Ich finde es nicht, weil er sagt auch grauenhaft. Aber man hat es sofort genutzt und gesagt, ja wir müssen ja die Terrorabwehr machen und da müssen wir jetzt Steuererhöhung. Das sind Vorwände, das sind alles Vorwände, denn wir wissen doch alle, dass wenn die Zigaretten 50 Cent mehr kosten, dass man damit mit Sicherheit nicht den Laden davon abhält, den nächsten Terroranschlag zu verüben, oder? Das sind doch nur Vorwände.
Ich finde zwei ganz wichtige Punkte hast du da aufgebracht. Das eine ist, dass wir da bloß Vorwände sehen. Im Internet gibt es das Bild der vier apoklyptischen Reiter, und zwar übrigens schon seit 15 Jahren. Das sind genau irgendwie die Bomben-Schmeisser, die Kinderficker, die bösen Raubkopierer. Und ach, den vierten habe ich schon wieder vergessen. Ich denke allerdings nicht, dass Steuern erhöhen der Zweck ist. Steuern erhöhen ist immer bloß der Endeffekt, der dabei hinten rauskommt. Sondern was der Zweck ist, ist, dass jemand hinstellt und sagt, ich brauche hier mehr Macht, mehr Einfluss, mehr Mitarbeiter. Und das kostet dann mehr Geld, und deswegen werden die Steuern erhöht. Aber ich denke, das eigentliche Problem ist das steigende Machtinteresse.
Was ich auf jeden Fall mache, zeigt in der Art, wie da zensiert wird. Also wer das darf, wie die Listen. Also dass das BKA selbst entscheiden kann. Hier muss zensiert werden, weil Kinder-Porno. Und wenn jemand ein Problem damit hat, kann er sich ja bei uns beschweren.
Dankeschön. Den anderen Punkt fand ich auch gut, die Geschichte mit den Hausdurchsuchungen. Es ist einfach so, dass wir in einer unglaublichen komplexen Welt mit unglaublich vielen Regeln leben. Und vieles auch darauf basiert, dass ein stillschweigendes Übereinkommen existiert, dass halt manche Gesetze gebrochen werden. Sei das die Millionen Kiffer, die es gibt, oder auch Sachen, die man einfach nicht möchte, dass irgendjemand weiß, dass, keine Ahnung, wenn man heimlich schwul ist, oder irgendwie noch eine Freundin nebenbei hat und so weiter und so fort.
Was möglicherweise nicht verboten ist.
Was möglicherweise nicht verboten ist, aber was im Zweifelsfall belastbares Material gegen dich ist. Und je mehr es davon gibt, desto größer wird der Anteil in der Bevölkerung, der im Zweifelsfall erpressbar ist, der halt genau nicht den Mund aufmachen kann, wenn es mal ein Problem gibt in der Gesellschaft, wenn wir mal irgendeinen Politiker loswerden müssen, weil er halt korrupt ist und an einer wichtigen Stelle sitzt. Und der letzte Punkt, den ich interessant für, den du angesprochen hattest, war die Was-ist-Kinder-Pornogeschichte. Und das ist in der Tat ein großes Problem. Da wurde übrigens auch durch Frau von der Leyen im letzten November das Gesetz geändert. Und es gibt jetzt also den neu dazugekommenen Straftatbestand der Jugendpornografie. Und der anscheinend minderjährigen, das heißt jemand, der so aussieht, als könnte er unter 18 sein, abzubilden, ist schon strafbar.
Das traf dann unter anderem die Bravo, die ja seit 30, 40 Jahren Aufklärung macht und Aufklärungsseiten auch hat.
Genau, genau. Und wie, die mussten die rausnehmen, die Seiten?
Nee, die mussten sie nicht rausnehmen, aber das ist ja genau das Beispiel.
Aber es geht auch weiter, die Comics finde ich ein gutes Beispiel. Da wurden keine Kinder missbraucht, als jemand irgendwie einen Bart Simpson Comic gezeichnet hat. So was soll das eigentlich? Vladimir Nabokovs Lolita ist bei ausreichend strenger Auslegung des neuen Gesetzes verboten und dabei handelt es sich um Weltliteratur. Also wir haben ja auch, das ist ein Bestandteil dieses Komplexes, einen deutlichen konservativen Rollback, wo gesagt wird, alles was irgendwie mit Sex zu tun hat unter 18 ist, ist Fouibé und am liebsten sollen die alle Jungfrau bleiben. Das ist doch das, was da im Endeffekt hinten rauskommt.
Ja, man hat ja auch den Eindruck, dass in den letzten Jahren, ich weiß nicht, vor 5, 6 Jahren, da lief im Fernsehen noch wahre Liebe und na gut, da kann man denken, was man will zu. Aber da war die Stimmung irgendwie auch generell so ein bisschen aufgeschlossen. Heute habe ich das Gefühl, dass das alles immer mehr zensiert wird. Also irgendwie alles, man sieht im Fernsehen auch kaum noch so Softwareotik-Filme oder so. Nicht, dass ich das jetzt unbedingt hier irgendwie sagen würde, dass ich da Fan bin oder so, aber ich sehe das auch als ein Stück Freiheit. Also irgendwie scheint man überall zu reglementieren. Ich bin selber nicht Drauchhaber. Ich sterbe nicht, wenn jemand im Restaurant mir eine Zigarette sich anzündet. Also ich weiß nicht, man hat das Gefühl, es wird alles reglementiert. Und ich vermute meistens wirtschaftliche Interessen dahinter. Oder halt Interessen, Machtinteressen.
Welche Interessen dahinter liegen und was die möglichen wirklichen Beweggründe sind, das können wir in dieser Sendung unter anderem diskutieren. Dazu ist sie ja auch da. Wie Nibbler, wohin so schön sagt, die Leute sind immer nur die erste Scheibe von Salami und nicht das dritte und das vierte, was dahinter steht, das versuchen wir heute in diesen zwei Stunden ein bisschen zu beleuchten. Mit euch zusammen natürlich am Telefon, 0331 70 97 110. Anderson Ronn, danke euch für den Anruf. Tschüss. Tschüss, wir müssen mal kurz mal sagen, wie spät es ist. Nämlich um 11. Chaosradio auf Fritz mit Andreas Mitnimmler, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir reden heute über die geplante Sperrung vom Internet mit euch unter 0331 70 97 110. Wir haben schon ein bisschen versucht uns dem Thema zu nähern, was steht eigentlich wirklich dahinter, wenn es denn nicht die Bekämpfung von Kinderpornografie ist. Und auch die Frage, was können wir alle, du, ich, wer auch immer jetzt gerade hört, was können wir tun, wenn wir sagen, wir sehen das alles ein bisschen anders als die gesetzgebenden Organe und wir würden gerne unsere Meinung dazu äußern. Da könnt ihr auch gerne hier anrufen und mitreden. Der nächste am Telefon ist Fidel. Hallo Fidel, guten Abend. Hallo, ich hab dich jetzt eine halbe Stunde vertröstet, aber hier ist echt Alarm am Telefon. Ich hoffe, du bist nicht sauer. Okay, wie gehst du denn damit um, dass diese Internetsperrgesetze auf uns zukommen?
Also, was ich ganz besonders bedenklich finde, ist eigentlich die Tatsache, dass ich bei dieser ganzen Diskussion um diese Internetsperrung, um einen doch sehr technischen Aspekt handel, der tatsächlich aber sehr weitreichende Auswirkungen hat. Und letztlich und endlich aber der, ja, wie soll man es nennen, heißt immer demokratischer Diskurs, tatsächlich eine Diskussion von Blinden über Farben ist. Kein Mensch wie ich eigentlich tatsächlich, sowohl von den Entscheidern als auch jetzt von den, sag ich mal, diskutierenden demokratischen Bevölkerungselementen, worum es eigentlich geht, worum es da eigentlich was damit bezweckt oder...
Trotzdem wird viel darüber diskutiert überall?
Genau, also da kann man jetzt halt auf diese technische Maßnahme kann man jetzt hier beliebige Emblemen wurfen kreben. Aktuellen Dingen ist es halt Kinderpornografie. Man könnte jetzt auch Bombenbauanleitung oder irgendeinem Emblem da drauf kreben. Letzten und Endes würde das auf der Zelle hinauslaufen und eigentlich weiß keiner worum es geht und denkt immer nur davon ab, welche Emblemen von der agierenden Fraktion draufgeklebt wird. Und danach wird entschieden. Das ist eine sehr polemische Diskussion, die eigentlich nicht wirklich von Sachkenntnis geprägt ist, sondern eben von Gefühlsduselei.
Fühlst du dich dann über diese Thema ausreichend informiert?
Ausreichend informiert in welcher Form? Also auf technischer Basis, denke ich, fühle ich mich ausreichend informiert, wovon diese Leute da denken zu sprechen. Ich sehe den aber an, dass sie nicht wissen, wovon die sprechen.
Wie ist es, Nübler und Andreas, wie ist es bei euch? Ihr gebt ja auch als Chaos Computer Club eine Menge Interviews zum Thema. Wie ist denn der Konsens in den Fragen? Gibt es immer wieder dieselben Geschichten, die angesprochen werden? Habt ihr das Gefühl, dass eine größere Sensibilität dafür vorherrscht oder interessiert es schlichtweg einen Haufen Leute einfach nicht?
Verschiedene Erfahrungen, die ich gemacht habe, ist, dass man durchaus mit vielen Leuten redet, die ein Verständnis dafür haben. Einige schaffen es in ihren Medien, das auch rüberzubringen. Andere liefern bloß das Schnittmaterial ab, das dann von irgendeiner Newsredaktion verwustet wird, wo die Aussagen dann wirklich nicht ankommen am anderen Ende. Und ich finde das Wort Propaganda hier wirklich nicht ganz unangebracht, weil die Diskussion völlig emotional und faktenfrei geführt wird.
Ein sehr polarisierendes Thema auch.
Ich wurde halt auch nur in den Medien transportiert und auch nur in so einen zerhackstückelten Propagandaschnipseln, die eben von irgendwelchen Redakteuren ausgesucht werden. Und da werden eben so eine Kernsätze dann immer wieder rausgeschnipselt und das läuft dann wirklich auf Propagandaremixes hinaus. Die Filter wirken nicht, die Filter wirken nicht, die Filter sind zu kurz. Also was soll der nächste politische Schritt sein? Dann gibt es eben ja die Packet-Inspection und längere Filter und chinesische Verhältnisse und irgendwie noch zehn Angestellte beim BKA mehr, weil die Liste wird ja immer länger. Und wo sonst soll sich da auch die Leistungsbemessung irgendwie durchsetzen als an der Liste, die immer länger wird, weil wenn die Liste kürzer werden würde, dann würden ja diese Angestellten am Ende irgendwie schlechte Arbeit leisten. Also muss die Liste immer länger werden, per Definition, per Selbstbegräts sozusagen. Das sind genau all diese Gefahren, die da mit geschaffen werden, per politischen Willen unter dem Emblem jetzt gerade Kinderpornografie. Nicht, dass man da wirklich andere Dinge gegen tun könnte. Wirkliche Leute mit die Sagaia schlusslich im Westen vor irgendwelchen belgischen Wohnungen mal die Türen eintreten ließe. Nein, jetzt werden hier irgendwelche DNS-Sperren integriert, implementiert.
Ja, wo du gerade Belgien sagtest, da gab es ja den Fall Dutou, wo also auch ein...
Ja, ich möchte da keine wirklichen Klischees ziehen, aber Belgien liegt einfach zu wie auf der Zunge.
Das war auf jeden Fall Klischee, aber wir halten uns fest.
Das ist aber ein prominentes Beispiel und das verdeutlicht auch ein Teil des Problems, dass nämlich die Leute, die tatsächlich Kindervergewaltigen, die solche Ringe betreiben, wo Kinder ins Land geschmuggelt, dann missbraucht und hinterher getötet werden, die gibt es wirklich, die gibt es da draußen und das sind teilweise auch hohe Politiker drin verwickelt. So, ich möchte mich jetzt hier nicht zu weit aus dem Fenster lehnen, weil ich die Fakten lange nicht kenne, aber...
Du stehst schon ganz schön im Rahmen eigentlich.
Wo man mit Diamanten bezahlt, wo kriegt man Diamanten? Keine Ahnung, so eine Sachen kann man da durch die Hose.
Aber dann wird es unsachlich.
Das wird auf jeden Fall unsachlich. Wir rudern mal ganz schnell zurück und holen auch Andreas wieder vom Fensterbrett weg.
Ich sag nochmal Sachsen-Sumpf-Google und mehr sag ich nicht mehr.
Ja, also was ich eigentlich so der Kern nochmal, wo ich eigentlich ansetzen wollte, ist, ob an dieser Stelle überhaupt eine demokratische Entscheidung auf breiter Basis überhaupt möglich ist, aufgrund dieser doch sehr strengen technischen Tatsache des Kerns, um den es eigentlich geht.
Wahrscheinlich ist diese Diskussion um diese technische Tatsache, diese Internetsperren, wir haben es ja schon mal ganz kurz angesprochen, ist auch etwas, wo viele Leute sagen, wow, davon habe ich keine Ahnung, damit will ich auch nichts...
Genau, da ist wirklich die Gefahr, dass die Leute da eben wie immer abwinken, ach Computer, damit kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Davon habe ich keine Ahnung, damit will ich nichts zu tun haben und da werden sich schon genug Leute damit beschäftigt haben, damit es funktioniert.
Das wissen die Experten, die immer im Fernsehen sprechen.
Ach und Kinderporno, das betrifft mich ja gar nicht.
Genau, Kinderporno ist schlimm, das muss weg und deswegen ja. Und was dort tatsächlich hinter dieser eigentlichen, hinter diesem ja macht mal, steht, das ist eben aufgrund der technischen Komplexität überhaupt niemandem bewusst, dass man dort wieder, naja...
Also ich habe festgestellt, dass es durchaus so ein Generation Gap ist. Wenn man mit Leuten redet, die Internet benutzen, selbst wenn es in Anführungszeichen nur normale Benutzer sind, denen ist klar, dass man mal auf einen Link draufklickt, auf den man nie raufklicken wollte, dass das passiert. Und dass man dann, wenn man denen erklärt, naja, dann hast du morgen eine Hausdurchsuchung, dann gucken die auch. Also auch wenn man auch...
Ja, haben sie im schlimmsten Fall noch eine schlimme Rechnung gehabt, die sie stillschweigend bezahlt haben und heutzutage ist es dann gleich eine Hausdurchsuchung irgendwie.
Viel auf jeden Fall hast du hier einen sehr interessanten Aspekt mit in Diskussionen gebracht, nämlich dass die technische Art und Weise, wie die Argumente ausgetauscht werden, also die Argumente über den technischen Ablauf, viele Leute schlicht und ergreifend einfach abschreckt, sich damit zu beschäftigen. Vielleicht sollten sich da einige Stellen von Medien bis hin zu jedem von uns, der sich mit dem Thema beschäftigt, das auch mal auf die Nase schreiben, das möglichst einfach und möglichst simpel zu erklären, ohne sofort in technisches Fachgelaber auszuweichen, wo die Hälfte der Leute dann wieder sagt, boah, hab ich keine Ahnung von, versteh ich nicht. Vielleicht auch ein Ansatz, über den wir mal nachdenken können. Vielen Dank dir für den Anruf. 0331 70 97 110. Wir reden heute im Chaosradio auf Fritz über Internetsperren. Und ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen, was ihr von diesem anstehenden Gesetz haltet, was hier auf uns zurollt. Wir hören kurz ein Stückchen Musik, danach geht's gleich weiter. Reality Detached von Forth im Chaosradio auf Fritz, Mittwochabend 0331 77 91 10. Wir reden über das geplante Gesetz zu den Sperren von bestimmten Seiten im Internet und ihr ruft an unter 0331, das habe ich eben schon mal gesagt, naja ihr wisst das schon. Der nächste am Telefon ist Björn, guten Abend Björn, ich grüße dich. Von wo rufst du an?
Ganz genau, der der letzte Mal auch schon da war. Jo, es geht mir um Folgendes. Es geht bei diesen Gesetze darum, quasi das Internet kaputt zu machen und Grundrechte einzuschränken. Und bevor die Technik klar ist, halten die auf der Pressekonferenz ein Schild hoch. Das ist doch Symbol oder finden Politiker sondergleich nicht. Wenn die Technik nicht steht, dann macht man doch keine Gedanken darüber, wie das Stoppschild am Ende aussieht.
Achso, du meinst jetzt, dass diese Website, die gesperrt sind, dass auf denen dann ein Stoppschild zu sehen ist, wie im Straßenverkehr, auf dem steht dann drauf zensiert.
Ja, das hatten sie ja in der Pressekonferenz.
In welcher anderen Form soll ein Internetausdrucker sonst so eine Seite hochhalten?
Kennt leicht nicht die Steigerung von Internetausdruckern?
Nee, da bin ich jetzt gespannt.
Das ist Internetausdrucker und wieder Einscanner. Ich hab neulich einen GIF gesehen von einer ausgedruckten und eingescannten Website.
Das ist schon ein bisschen älter, aber das ist wirklich großartig.
Es gibt auch Leute, die drucken E-Mails aus, um mir den Anhang zu zeigen, um mich zu fragen, was für eine Datei ist. So nach dem Motto, wird das funktionieren bei denen. Da stellt sich mir nur die Frage, das ist ja wohl kaum Politik, die sich nach irgendwelchen vernünftigen Idealen richtet. Wenn ich da noch von Geschichten wie die Synthen dazu höre, dass dann irgendwelche nekkischen Bilder der Synthen sensiert werden. Da wurde ja keiner bei Verletzt wird. Das ist doch reine Machtbulerei, wenn sich da die Politik mal weniger an ihren dummen Idealen, woher sie auch immer kommen mögen, und mehr an der goldene Regel orientieren würden.
Aber die Frage ist, was machen wir denn damit? Die Einsicht, dass unsere Politiker offensichtlich gerade wenig Ahnung haben von dem, was sie tun auf bestimmten Themenbereichen und relativ rücksichtslos in Fakten vorbei agieren. Wie gehen wir damit um als Gesellschaft? Was machen wir da?
Also eine Maßnahme von mir wäre, dass ich von allein mal ein paar nette Mails schreibe, wenn noch ein paar mitschreiben würden, und der dann schildere, dass ich deren Sperre innerhalb von 30 Sekunden umgehen könnte und diese 30 Sekunden meines Lebens nicht zurück bekomme, sodass die jetzt diese Mail lesen muss, dass sie dann 30 Sekunden ihres Lebens kosten wird. Wenn das genug sind, könnte man die Frau vielleicht mal zum Nachdenken anregen. Aber ich denke, wenn die vielleicht zur Einsicht kommen würde, dann gibt es den nächsten Doofen, der dann so ein Ungepasst haben will.
Das scheitert an der Realität, glaubst du? Sie liest ihre Mail selber?
Ja, das ist auch das Problem.
Und die Sache, sie hat ja selbst gesagt, dass es da diese 20 Prozent der Kinderschänder im Internet gibt, die das umgeben.
Wenn du weißt, wie man das umgeht, dann bist du ein Kinderschänder. Das ist irgendwie ihre Gedankenwelt dazu.
Ja, danke. Ich freue mich drüber, dass ich ein Kinderschänder bin. Ich bin eine gute Frau von allein. Was mich da interessieren würde, wenn ich sowieso schon ein Kinderschänder bin, wo ist denn dieses Stoppschild? Gibt es da schon eine IP-Adresse? Ich brauche eine neue Startseite.
Es gibt diverse Entwürfe im Netz. Mir fällt aber gerade keine Ohle ein. Kannst du suchen. Also es gibt auch diverse Verfälle. Bei der Titanic gibt es eine sehr schöne Version.
Die kenne ich auch eigentlich sonst.
Aber ich möchte gleich auf die richtige gehen.
Nee, die gibt es noch nicht. Die Provider haben gesagt, sie brauchen jetzt noch ein bisschen. Die Telekom hat gesagt, sie braucht sechs Monate. Das interpretiere ich mal als bis nach der nächsten Wahl. Ja, die Telekom hat sich sehr gewehrt.
Es hat nicht nur die Telekom, es haben sich einige Provider. In der letzten Sendung im Januar, als wir noch darüber gesprochen haben, war es ja noch so, dass das Ministerium mit den Providern reden wollte und sie dann davon überzeugen wollte, dass sie da mitmachen. Und nicht alle Provider fanden das cool, weil es auch hieß, die technische Umsetzung ist viel zu kompliziert und ist alles unglaublich teuer und eigentlich wären sie nicht dabei. Jetzt sind sie trotzdem alle im Boot. Was ist da passiert?
Daraufhin ist QSC aus dem Privatkundengeschäft ausgestiegen. Ob man das jetzt miteinander verknüpfen möchte oder nicht, sind wir dahingestellt. Aber es ist für die Provider zunehmend riskanter mit Privatpersonen mit Internet zu beliefern, weil man nicht weiß, was man da an Infrastruktur seinen Kunden in den Weg stellen muss.
Hatte ich vorhin schon erwähnt, der Herr Riesenhuber, der bei Kabel Deutschland und bei Vodafone eine sehr einflussreiche Position hat, ein Parteifreund der Frau von der Leyen ist. Ich denke, das hängt damit zusammen. Auch wenn man sich die Leute anguckt, dieses Betreiben scheint ein kleiner elitärer Zirkel zu sein. Man fragt sich immer, was der Wirtschaftsminister damit zu tun ist. Er hat ja den Gesetzesentwurf geschrieben und stellt dann fest, dass seine Frau, also die Chefin eines Adelige trinken Sekt und machen Benefits Vereins ist, der sich also dem Kampf gegen Kindesmissbrauch gewidmet hat, wo lauter Fonds drin sitzen. Und das sind die, die den Stein ins Rollen gebracht haben für diese Aktion, die also losgelaufen sind zum Innenminister und zu Frau von der Leyen und die maßgeblich daran beteiligt waren, überhaupt die politische Diskussion in Gang zu bringen.
Was man noch zu dem Thema sagen könnte, ist, dass es auf Netzpolitik.de einen sehr netten Artikel mit den sieben Lügen, der von der Frau von der Leyen gibt, der sehr lesenswert ist. Und zum anderen gibt es auf Wikileaks einen, ich weiß nicht, wie originalgetreuen Brief eines, einem aus dieser Kinderpornoszene, der beschreibt, was da passiert, um mal die andere Richtung zu sehen. Ich weiß aber nicht, wie authentisch das ist.
Also die angesichts der da doch drin befindlichen Verharmlosung des Missbrauchs von Kindern würde ich davon ausgehen, dass er authentisch ist. Also der beschäftigt sich in der Hälfte des Textes damit, sein Verhalten zu rechtfertigen. In der anderen Hälfte redet er darüber, wie die Szene aussieht. Ist ein bisschen eine sehr schmerzhafte Lektüre, aber ich halte den für authentisch.
Okay, also, Bjarne aus Hannover braucht auf jeden Fall eine neue Startseite und einen neuen Clown, denn den anderen hat er heute früh zum Frühstück schon verspeist. 03317797110. Der nächste Anruf kommt aus München. Servus nach München, guten Abend.
Ja, guten Abend, hallo.
Hallo, wie heißt du?
Walidom.
Hallo Walidom, was ist das für ein Name, der ist ja abgefahren.
Ja, ist nur ein Internet-Künstlername. Ich habe übrigens eine Startseite für den Vorredner.
Für Bjarne, ja?
Ja, das ist www.kinderpornos.info.
Also eine wunderschöne Seite mit einer richtig schönen Startseite vom Bundes-Sicherheitshauptamt.
Noch ein Clown zum Frühstück. Alles klar, lass mal zum Thema zurückkommen, Internet sperren.
Ich will mal zurückkommen, worauf ich hinwollte, es wurde sehr viel argumentiert in der Richtung, dass diese Sperren wirkungslos wären oder nicht hundertprozentig wirksam sind. Das halte ich für eine sehr gefährliche Debatte oder überhaupt das Argument zu nehmen. Aus dem Grund, weil es, ich bin Techniker, relativ mit vertretbarem Aufwand möglich ist, zumindest andere DNS-Server auszusperren. Das ist eine oder zwei Firewalls-Regeln, da werden mir die Leute vom CCC vielleicht zustimmen. Um zu sagen, du darfst nur diesen DNS-Server benutzen und keinen anderen. Das ist mit Sicherheit eine noch weiter gesteigerte Wirkung.
Ja und eine noch weiter aufgebaute Filterung. Das ist genau die Geschichte mit, dann haben wir chinesische Verhältnisse, weil dann komme ich und verkaufe VPN-Dienste und dann fängst du an VPN-Verkehr zu sperren.
Genau und sonst dreht sich die Spirale immer weiter. Kommt dann weiterhin dazu, denkbare Möglichkeit, wer das versucht zu umgehen, den Alleinschutt ist, schlafbar zu machen. Das ist also eine Sache, wo ich mich gar nicht darauf einlassen wollte, auf so eine Diskussion. Sondern ich will vielmehr auf eine grundsätzliche Diskussion hin, wo gesagt wird, okay, was ist denn der Vergleich Pressefreiheit und freier Informationszugang und alle diese Themen, die wir immer wieder ansprechen, im Vergleich. Und das ist jetzt wirklich böse und ich bin wirklich absolut gegen Kinderpornos und ihr habt mich schon im Netz gegen Kinderpornos und Hacker gegen Kinderpornos und wie sie alle heißen in 90ern, falls ihr euch erinnern könnt, schon engagiert und habt da viel gemacht. Aber jetzt wirklich mal auf einer grundsätzlichen Ebene, wenn ich den Missbrauch oder das Anschauen, nicht den Missbrauch selbst, sondern das Anschauen von solchem Material im Vergleich zu einer grundsätzlichen Infrastrukturstelle, mit der ich Sensor betreiben kann, wie beantworte ich die Frage, was ist hier wichtiger?
Das ist halt genau die Geschichte und deswegen muss man diese Argumentation mit der Wirksamkeit leider bringen. Du hast dann eine Abwägung von Grundrechten gegeneinander.
Das hatten wir ja eingangs schon mal.
Das hatten wir ja eingangs schon mal. Ich sage es gern nochmal, weil das ist der entscheidende Punkt in der Debatte. Es ist eine Grundrechtsabwägung und natürlich ist sozusagen die Einschränkung des Rechts auf Meinungs- und Informationsfreiheit viel einschneidender als etwas, was sowieso gar nicht wirksam ist. Also das ist einfacher, diesen Punkt zu machen. Wenn du die Wirksamkeit nicht betrachtest, hast du eine sehr viel, sehr viel schwierigere Diskussion zu rechtfertigen. Dann kommen die Leute wirklich und sagen irgendwie, ihr wollt doch aber bloß Kinderpornos gucken.
Alleine, dass wir uns die Frage stellen, dass wir uns eine Gelegenheit darüber machen, zeigt, dass irgendwo was versagt haben muss. Also dass da nicht nachgegangen wird, dass da nicht die Quellen bekämpft werden.
Das ist eigentlich die Richtung, wo wir auch hin sollten. Wir sollten sagen, warum werden die Quellen nicht bekämpft. Warum stellen wir fest, dass Schwedischen und Australischen kaum Kinderpornos sind, sondern Schwulenseiten und Lolita-Seiten, die nichts mit Kinderpornos zu tun haben, die nach deutschem Recht nicht strafbar sind. Dann zu sagen, lasst uns die Diskussion auf dieser Ebene führen und nicht dahin gehen, diese Wirksamkeit zu bezweifeln. Weil das heißt, man hat nur am Rückschluss, dass man sagt, dann machen wir es einfach wirksam, Merle.
Wenn du die Argumentation bringst, wirst du folgende Gegenargumentation bekommen. Das ist ja natürlich, tun wir schon alles für die Strafverfolgung, was wir können, aber wir müssen ja ganzheitlich eingreifen und wir müssen den Markt austrocknen und wir müssen dafür sorgen, dass die Nachfrage nicht da ist.
Okay, dann weißt du, genauso wie ich, dass die Nachfrage nach kommerziellen Angeboten nicht nachgewiesen ist, dass der kommerzielle Markt nicht vorhanden ist oder zumindest nicht nachgewiesen wurde an Studien. Heute hast du eine Studie auf dem Tisch gekriegt von einer IWF aus Großbritannien, die sagen oder haben halt relativ wenig kommerzielle Webseiten finden können und die, die wirklich kommerzielle Webseiten mit solchen Inhalten sind, seien in Ländern, in denen die Verfolgung relativ einfach möglich sein sollte. Das heißt, auch da ist nicht die Wirksamkeit, sondern die Sinnhaftigkeit einer Zensur nicht gegeben, weil man das einfach abschalten kann.
Lass uns das mal weitermachen, weil vielleicht kommen wir noch zu interessanten Punkten. Dann ist das nächste Argument, was du hören wirst, dass die Kinderpornos sozusagen eine Einstiegsdroge sind, dass also die Leute, die sich das angucken, irgendwann losgehen und tatsächlich Kinder vergewaltigen und wenn man sie davon fernhält, dann passiert vielleicht nicht so viel.
Also, ich bin jetzt kein Experte, und ich kenne mit dem AKS-Zensur, das ist jetzt so ein kleiner Kreis von Leuten, die sich dagegen engagieren, gibt es ein paar Leute, die vom Missbrauch, vom Kreis von Missbrauchspfand stammen. Die da wirklich mitarbeiten und selbst als Kind missbraucht worden sind und sich jetzt gegen diese Zensur wehren. Und die haben gesagt, die Leute aus ihrer Erfahrung, die Leute, die wirklich Kinder missbrauchen, haben eigentlich einen ganz anderen Hintergrund. Die haben ein Defizit an Kontroll, also ein psychologisches Problem mit erwachsenen Frauen zum Beispiel umzugehen.
Ich bin wie gesagt überhaupt kein Experte in dem Thema.
Nur, ich glaube einfach nicht daran, dass das eine Einstiegsdroge ist. Das könnte man weitertreiben, indem man sagt, jeder der sich Porno-Seiten ansieht und sich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, die Team-Pornos rein zieht, das wird ja über kurz oder lang auf Kinder-Pornos scharf sein. Das ist für mich keine Acht vor Unbelegten, das will ich mir mal zeigen.
Es erinnert sich ein bisschen an die Argumentationen der fundamentalen Christen in den USA, die sagen, wir müssen was gegen die schwule Propaganda tun, damit unsere Kinder nicht alle schwul werden.
Ja, genau das. Und das Nächste ist, das zu leisten mit Hut. Und das tut mir echt leid. Wir müssen alles gegen Kinder-Porno tun, im Rahmen, in der Verhältnismäßigkeit, aber in der Gesellschaft, dass leider bei den vielen Deppten, die bei uns rumlaufen, immer wieder vorkommen. Und die müssen wir festnageln, die müssen wir entsprechend behandeln, aber das komplett auszublenden, diese chinesische Schutzwand davor zu stellen, bringt gar nichts.
Okay.
Letzte Frage an dich nochmal, Walidom. Du hast ja am Anfang auch gesagt, du bist Techniker, kennst dich also mit den ganzen Maßnahmen auch aus und wir hatten vorhin ja schonmal die Meinung, dass die Diskussion um das Thema eigentlich schon auf einem sehr technischen Niveau geführt wird, wo viele Leute sagen, da habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf. Die Leute, die sich das ausgedacht haben, werden schon wissen, was sie da tun und ich winke das mal ab. Was glaubst du, wie man dagegen wirken kann, wie man eine größere Sensibilität für das Thema schaffen kann, um, wie Nibla vorhin so schön sagte, die zweite und die dritte Scheibe der Salami zu sehen, nicht nur die erste, wo die Schlagzeile draufsteht?
Einmal müssen wir es schaffen, die Medien auch mit den kritischen Argumenten ein bisschen zu bearbeiten. Da gibt es eine Pressematte vom Ackerzensur im Internet, einfach Google Ackerzensur, da gibt es eine Pressematte mit den sämtlichen Argumenten, die zusammengefasst sind. Das zweite ist, wir müssen im Internet vertreten sein, indem wir so Banner einbinden wie so ein Kinderpornos.info, da gibt es so ein Banner, wo draufsteht, morgen früh kommen die BKA-Leute mit Sturmgewehr im Anschlag in deine Bude gerannt, weil du diesen Banner nachgeladen hast von einer gesperrten Internetseite, um Leute im Siebel zu machen.
Den Leuten zu sagen, die jetzt sagen, ich habe nichts zu verbergen, denen mitzuteilen, doch du hast was zu verbergen.
Richtig. Genau, indem die Leute in die Realität holen. Und das dritte ist natürlich politische Aktionen, Herr Schäuble ist zum Beispiel am 7. Mai in Karlsruhe und spricht zum Thema Internetzensur oder Internetfilter und da kann man, ich wohne da nicht, aber wer da auch immer jetzt zuhört, da kann man hingehen und da mal ein Fähnchen hochhalten.
Zum Beispiel.
Oder andere Aktionen machen, wichtig ist, die Leute erreichen und ja, Revolution 2.0 gegen Stadio 2.0, ja.
Walidom, danke dir für den Anruf. Servus nach München. Ihr seid im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Wir reden über die geplanten Sperren im Internet, die Zensur von Webseiten. Der nächste Anruf kommt aus Paderborn von Patrick, guten Abend, Patrick. Grüß dich. Was hältst du davon, dass dieses Gesetz auf uns zurollt und dass demnächst Stoppschilder durchs Internet kursieren?
Ja, also zu der Wirkungslosigkeit kann man sich ja gerne noch streiten. Wie wir es ja vorhin schon gesagt haben, das kann mit 5W durchaus umgehen, aber es wird jeder unter einen Generalverdacht gestellt, was schon bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung eigentlich erfolgt.
Genau, die ist in der ganzen Diskussion doch, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, eigentlich gar nicht mehr so auf. An die haben wir uns alle schon gewöhnt.
Richtig, genau und der Wiederruf, der beim Bundesgerichtshof läuft, ist ja noch lange nicht durch. Das ist ja der Generalverdacht, der dann da zukommt und der Kennzeichenabgleich von den ganzen Mautterminals, da lassen sich ja nicht nur die LKW-Kennzeichen abgleichen, sondern auch die PKW-Kennzeichen, durchaus, ohne Probleme. Und wir haben in Deutschland einen Zentralregister, das heißt wir können gucken, wem welches Auto gehört. Das ist ja natürlich auch alles möglich und machbar.
Also zum Glück weiß ich bei der Maut aus gewöhnlich gut unterrichteten Kreisen, dass die PKW-Kennzeichenerfassung da noch nicht an ist.
Noch nicht, aber das ist auch glaube ich kein großes Problem, die anzuschalten.
Die Jungs wollen das auch nicht, weil es ist mehr Aufwand beim Administrieren.
Wir wollen gar nicht weiterfragen, aber wie ist das, wenn ich einen kleinen Laster fahre, der jetzt noch kein 40 Tonner ist?
Der Punkt ist, wenn du mautpflichtig bist, fallen Daten an.
Solange mein Auto nicht sagt, ich bin mautpflichtig, ist alles cool.
Ja, solange du nicht mautpflichtig bist, ist alles cool. Wenn du mautpflichtig bist, wird dein Kennzeichen verarbeitet oder du hast so eine Box, die irgendwie sagt, wo du gerade bist. Und diese Daten werden vom Bunde, vom Zoll, genau der Zoll ist zuständig, die Aufsicht über die private Firma zu führen und nachzugucken, ob die Maut auch ordentlich abgerechnet wird. Und dazu brauchen sie natürlich eine Kopie aller Daten.
Wieder was gelernt. Danke Andreas vom CCC. So, aber zurück zu Patrick aus Paderborn.
Und ich finde, dass in den meisten Zeitungen auch sehr viel Propaganda gemacht wird. Also wenn man mal eine große Tageszeitung aus Berlin und eine Tageszeitung aus der Mitte Deutschlands vergleicht, kommt man zu dem Schluss, dass in der Tageszeitung aus Berlin wesentlich mehr drinsteht als aus der Mitte Deutschland.
Was glaubst du, woran liegt das?
Das liegt a. in der Ausrichtung der Zeitung, ganz klar. Und an dem, wie politischen Köpfe dahinterstehen. Weil in deiner Zeitung steht immer ein Verlag und damit auch eine gewisse politische Ausrichtung. Auch die Bildzeitung hat irgendeine Ausrichtung.
Ach, das wäre jetzt aber neu.
Ja, je nachdem, woher der Wind grad weht. Das ist das einzigste. Aber grad nur die Wildleser, die werden sich so, oh, Kinderporno, oh, ganz böse und, ne. Dann machen wir das doch. Und darauf ist es momentan ausgelegt. Weil so eine Sperre, naja, Wirksamkeit kann man halt bezweifeln oder eben auch nicht, ist halt da auf diesem Niveau leider ausgelegt.
Aber wo du kleine Zeitungen sagtest, das halte ich für einen ganz wichtigen Punkt. Ja, wir können auch als CCC ja nicht mit allen Journalisten in diesem Lande reden, sondern wir müssen uns immer auf die beschränken, die wir gerade in unserer Freizeit noch abgearbeitet bekommen. Wenn ihr irgendwo seid, wo es kleinere Zeitungen gibt, versucht mit denen an die Journalisten reinzukommen, versucht mit denen zu reden, versucht denen das Problem zu erklären.
Und versucht ihnen vor allem klar zu machen, dass sie direkt selbst davon betroffen sind.
Ja genau, sie können morgen nicht mehr recherchieren, wenn das durch ist. Das müssen die glaube ich mal verstehen. Und da habe ich eine gewisse Hoffnung. Und es gibt ja zum Glück auch noch Parteien, die zufällig gerade nicht an der Regierung sind und deswegen dagegen. Und wenn man sich die entsprechende Zeitung raussucht, dann bekommt man vielleicht auch so einen Artikel unter.
Also so wie ich das gesehen habe, in den Blogs steht dann halt meistens, oder wirkliche Blogs, nicht Twitter, stehen halt Informationen, die man, ja genau, die man halt sonst nicht so zu lesen kriegt. Also was da so geplant ist. Kinderporno ist wirklich nur der große Fleck. Und dahinter kommt noch viel, viel mehr. Die Leute, die Dinge festzumachen, wäre viel einfacher. Da haben wir das BKA für. Und dann kann das die Leute auch gegebenenfalls festnehmen. Die haben doch jetzt irgendwo den Ungarn-Server hochgenommen. Irgendwie mit Rails-Daten. Warum geht das nicht mit Kinderpornografie? Das geht bestimmt auch. Nur das ist ein Aufwand, den die nicht treiben wollen. Da sagen die los, wir packen ein Label drauf, und dann ist Kinderporno erst mal zu. Zumindest für den nicht geschuldenen User.
Und stattdessen finden dann so Dinge wie Operation Himmel statt, wo mal eine breite Masse an Leuten beschuldigt wurde? Gab es da irgendwie ein einziges Verfahren?
Ich glaube, es gab ein paar Selbstmorde von Leuten, die beschuldigt waren, es aber gar nicht waren, weil ihre Kreditkartendaten geklaut waren.
Das waren die, wo über 12.000 Daten überprüft wurden?
Genau, die Rasterfahndung.
Das war das vor 2 Jahren etwa, oder 1, 5 Jahren?
Von übrigens dem einzigen Staatsanwalt in Deutschland, der sich um das Thema Kinderpornografie kümmert, der sitzt in Halle.
Ja, und was ich noch glaube, wir schaffen uns jetzt ein neues Feindbild. Osama bin Laden, soll er tot sein, also brauchen wir ein neues Feindbild.
Polemikmodus wieder aus.
Ja, ich weiß. Ich denke mal als Hintergrund, weil der Innenminister wird da bestimmt auch ein großes Interesse daran haben, dass es so einen Filter geben wird.
Es haben eine ganze Menge Leute ein Interesse daran. Wir haben es ja vorhin schon mal kurz erwähnt, es gibt Interesse vom Bildungsministerium, die sich Gewaltseiten wegsperren wollen, was auch immer das jetzt im Speziellen ist, ob es jetzt Killerspiele sind oder sonst was. Es gibt Interesse von der Musikindustrie, es gibt Interesse von der Filmindustrie, es gibt Interesse von Softwareherstellern, um Torrent-Tracker und alles andere zu machen. Und dann geht es natürlich hin von religiösen, antireligiösen, politischen Webseiten, wo auch immer irgendeine Befindlichkeit ist, von einer höheren Stelle, die sagt, das möchte ich bitte nicht der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich machen. Und dann sind wir an dem Punkt, an dem diese Internetsperren unter anderem auch eingreifen könnten. Und deswegen machen wir heute diese Sendung an dieser Stelle.
Ich denke mal, dass wir irgendwann, wenn wir das jetzt alles so weiterspinnen, bei chinesischen Verhältnissen landen. Und zwar noch viel schlimmer als das, was die momentan da haben, dass es dagegen noch harmlos ist. Und dann werden wir ohne Religion und Nation nicht mehr ins Internets kommen.
Deswegen ist es immer noch wichtig, mit den Leuten zu reden, mit eurer lokalen Zeitung zu reden, mit den Leuten um euch herumzureden, in der Klasse oder wo auch immer, auf Arbeit oder in der Uni, um einfach Argumente auszutauschen, um ein Interesse dafür zu schaffen. Weil sonst sagen alle Leute, oh Computer ey, kenn ihr mich sowieso nicht aus, wird schon irgendwie funktionieren. Patrick, danke dir für den Anruf.
Alles klar, tschüss.
Wir machen jetzt gleich Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr und danach geht es weiter hier im Chaos Radio auf Fritz mit euch 0331 70 97 110. Was wird uns da gerade eigentlich als Internetsperre verkauft und wie geht ihr damit um?
Mitten im Sommer bringt euch Fritz Clueso, Selig, Klee, Tele, Super 700 und Mia. Am 10.07. Fritz im Freim. Die Fritz Open Airs. Solang es doch Karten und Kombi-Tickets gibt, gibt es Karten und Kombi-Tickets überall, wo es Karten und Kombi-Tickets gibt. Und mehr Infos. Fritz die. Fritz im Freim. Die Fritz Open Airs in der Zitadelle Spandau. Einmal im Juli und einmal im August, aber immer im Freien. Und das hört man.
2,512. Mitkeit natürlich.
Die Weltgesundheitsorganisation WAO warnt immer deutlich vor einer möglichen Pandemie der Schweinegrippe. Sie hat das Risiko auf die zweithöchste Stufe 5 angehoben. Der Gesundheitszustand der drei deutschen Schweinegrippe-Patienten aus Hamburg und Bayern hat sich nach Angaben der zuständigen Gesundheitsbehörden inzwischen deutlich gebessert. Alle drei waren zuvor in Mexiko gewesen, wo die meisten Fälle der neuen Grippe registriert werden. Bundesaußenminister Steinmeier hat den jüngsten Anschlag auf die Bundeswehr in Afghanistan als feige und heimtückisch verurteilt. Bei dem Angriff war am Abend ein deutscher Soldat getötet und vier verletzt worden. Es war bereits der zweite Anschlag des Tages auf die Bundeswehr. Schon am Morgen waren fünf deutsche Soldaten bei einem Selbstmordantentat nalkundlos verletzt worden. Berlins Datenschutzbeauftragter Dix hat junge Leute davor gewarnt, zu viele persönliche Infos ins Internet zu stellen. Besonders bei sozialen Netzwerken wie Facebook oder StudiVZ rät er zur Vorsicht. Nutzer sollten nicht ungeschützt private Daten und Bilder online stellen. Das würde den Datenmissbrauch erleichtern. In der Fußball-Champions-League kann sich der englische Verein Manchester United Hoffnung machen, den Titel zu verteidigen. Im Halbfinale-Hinspiel schlug die Mannschaft Arsenal London 1 zu 0. Das Rückspiel wird am kommenden Dienstag in London ausgetragen. Hier sind noch die aktuellen Temperaturen. In Cottbus haben wir 11 Grad, Neuropin und Angermünde 12, Potsdam-Wittenberge 13, Frankfurt 14 und in Berlin Werte zwischen 14 und 15 Grad. Heute Nacht gibt es nur wenige Wolken und es ist deshalb auch meistens trocken. Die Temperaturen gehen runter bis auf 6 Grad. Morgen startet der Tag sonnig, aber dann später, besonders an der Elbe, gibt es auch mal ein bisschen Regen und vereinzelt auch Gewitter. Es bleibt aber sonst trocken bei bis zu 25 Grad. Und wir haben gleich drei Meldungen von der A10. Einmal vom westlichen Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck-Haffeland zwischen Potsdam Nord und Spandau. Da liegt ein totes Wildschwein auf der Fahrbahn. Bitte vorsichtig fahren. A10, nördlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck-Haffeland zwischen Birkenwerder und Kreuz Oranienburg. Dort liegt ein toter Fuchs auf der Fahrbahn. Und am östlichen Berliner Ring, auf der A10, Richtung Dreieck-Schwanenbeck zwischen Marzahn und Hohenschönhausen. Dort gibt es Gefahr durch einen defekten Tanklastzug. Dort ist die rechte Spur gesperrt. Und noch eine letzte Meldung von der A15, Dreieck-Spraywald Richtung Übergang Forst zwischen Rogghausen und Forst. Da hat ein Auto gebrannt. Dort gibt es jetzt Behinderung. Und der Verkehr wird einspurig vorbeigeleitet. Euch eine gute Fahrt.
Kai Tandürlich mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr, 5 nach halb 12.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB. Und wenn im Radio 89, 85, dann Fritz im Berliner Kabel.
Bortes vom Taucher, Chaosradio auf Fritz, Nibla ist hier und Andreas ist da vom CCC. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir reden über die angedachte oder schon als Gesetzentwurf vorliegende Planung, Webseiten im Netz zu sperren. Haben jetzt ganz viele Meinungen gehört, die sich dagegen stellen. Jetzt kommt eine Meinung pro und zwar von Chris aus Reinickendorf. Na, Chris? Grüß dich. Wieso bist du dafür?
Weil ich zweifacher Vater bin und daher werde ich das für, ja, positiv werden. Und wie ist es viel zu lush? Also ich meine, ich habe jetzt öfters die Nachrichten verfolgt und da ist es auf einmal, ja, wir brauchen noch ein halbes Jahr, bis alles umgeändert werden kann, wo ich dann auch schon wieder denke, so wir tun das Volk erstmal beruhigen, dass da was passiert, aber naja.
Wie siehst du denn die Seite der Kritiker, die sagen, es geht hier eigentlich gar nicht um die Eindämmung von Kinderpornografie, die ja sowieso schon unter Strafe steht und die viel einfacher zu bekämpfen wäre, sondern es geht eigentlich darum, langfristig eine Zensur im Internet einzuführen?
Na ja, scheiße. Also ich finde, die Leute, die meinen, es ist nicht so schlimm, die haben echt eine Klatsche, weil ich finde, so was überhaupt auf so eine Seite reinzugehen und auf Kinder zu stehen, ist echt Schwanz ab- und wegsperren. So lebenslänglich wegsperren, weil das kann nicht sein. Ich meine, jeder war Kind und wieso muss man, nur weil man aus einem zerrütteten Familienhaus oder eine schlechte Kindheit hat oder missbraucht wurde, das anderen Menschen antun. Also das ist zwar echt krank, natürlich ist es krank, aber wenn es nach mir geht, Todesstrafe, Schwanz ab-
Aber dir ist schon klar, dass diese Maßnahmen, die beschlossen werden, nicht dagegen helfen, dass deswegen kein Kind weniger verarbeitet wird.
Ich weiß, deswegen sollte man auch das Strafmaß erhöhen und nicht gleich, wenn es heißt, dass ein Psychologe sagt, er ist geheilt und trotzdem wieder die gleiche Scheiße baut. Das ist einfach scheiße, das System von der Justwiz in dem Punkt.
Aber es hat ja dann in dem Fall wenig zu tun mit den geplanten Sperrungen von Webseiten.
Wie gesagt, ich finde gut, dass es gemacht wird, nur es dauert mir zu lange, weil auf einmal heißt es, es dauert noch ein halbes Jahr, bis verschiedene Leute es schaffen, es umzusetzen.
Ich finde es also gut, dass die Energie darauf verschwendet wird, einen Fehler zu implementieren und nicht darauf, die Leute anzugehen, die mit so was handeln.
Also ich finde gut, dass es passiert und ich finde nicht gut, dass die Leute nicht an, also dass nicht auf die Leute zugegangen wird und gleich gesagt wird, hier komm, pack dir die Handschellen um und Tschüss.
Aber kannst du erklären, was du daran gut findest, nachdem wir festgestellt haben, es wird nicht helfen?
Es wird, also ich finde schon, dass es helfen wird, weil dann hat nicht mehr jeder die Möglichkeit. Natürlich werden sich irgendwelche Tunnels bauen, um irgendwie anders an so eine Seite ranzukommen, aber es ist erst mal ein Fortschritt. Andere vielleicht nicht, aber ich sehe es so.
Also dadurch, dass so Seiten ausgeblendet werden aus dem Internet, dadurch, dass man das nicht mehr wahrnimmt, dass da ein Problem besteht, dass da Leute austauschen, findest du, dass den Kindern geholfen wird?
Den Kindern wird noch nicht wirklich dadurch geholfen, aber es wird erst mal im Internet weggeschlossen.
Es wird ja nicht weggeschlossen, das ist ja das Punkt, aber es ist nicht weg.
Ganz im Gegenteil, man macht da die Augen zu und sagt, okay, die Seiten gehen uns jetzt nichts mehr an, das Problem anzugehen. Steht unter Strafe, aber was dagegen zu tun...
Man kann sie ja tatsächlich wegkriegen, indem man zu dem Rechner läuft, wo sie draufliegt, den mitnimmt und den Typen dann betreibt gleich auch mit.
Das ist ja eigentlich das Thema der heutigen Sendung, dass es eigentlich darum geht, dass solche Rechner oder solche Straftaten viel effektiver und viel schneller zu bekämpfen sind und viel schneller zu finden sind, weil ein Großteil der Rechner steht in Westeuropa, das ist erwiesen, und dann kann man relativ einfach den Provider entweder anschreiben oder gleich die Strafvermittlungsbehörden einschalten und dann sagen, da und da steht der und der Server und dann geht das relativ schnell. Deswegen ist dieses Instrument, was hier gerade installiert wird, und das ist ja das Thema der heutigen Sendung, die schön vom Nibbler gezitierte dritte Salamischeibe, es geht ja eigentlich um was ganz anderes und darüber wollen wir heute reden. Aber nochmal zurück zum Anfang, auch die anderen Leute haben ja gefragt, fühlst du dich in Ergänze über dieses Thema gut unterrichtet? Hast du das Gefühl, du hast da Durchblick und weißt, was da für ein Gesetz auf dich zukommt?
Es wurde nur gesagt, es werden jetzt Internetseiten, was darauf hinweist, dass es eine Pornografieseite ist, gesperrt. Aber es wurde noch nicht so viel berichtet, dass man daraus schlau wird. Es wurde einfach nur in den Raum geworfen, dass pornografische Seiten, die kinderpornografische Inhalte haben, gesperrt werden. Es ist einfach sowas in den Nachrichten gebracht. Und da lachte ich mir so, ist ja geil, wenigstens mal was. Es wird nicht irgendwelche Missbrauche davon verhindert, was auch scheiße ist.
Also das Gefühl hab ich halt auch bei dieser Maßnahme, dass es bloß darum geht, so zu demonstrieren, wir tun ja was. Also es geht eigentlich eher um den Showwert für die Politiker.
Die Politik steht dann erstmal wieder gut da. Irgendwo auf einer Seite.
Also ich meine, ich teile ja deine moralische Entrüstung darüber, was Kindern angetan wird. Aber genau auf der Welle schwimmt das ja. Und dann guckt man nicht mehr so genau hin. Das ist halt das Problem, das wir da haben.
Man sollte einfach mehr dafür tun. Man sollte einfach gucken, was die Kinder... Also man sollte seine eigenen Kinder einfach mehr begleiten und nicht überall mehr hingehen lassen, weil die meisten Eltern einfach ja Augen zu, hier hast du Geld und durch.
Ich finde wichtig ist auch nicht weggucken. Viele Missbrauchsfälle, die bekannt geworden sind, da haben schon irgendwie Leute so ein bisschen was mitbekommen. Aber keiner wollte das wahrhaben.
Weil sie einfach wussten, was auf sie zukommt, wenn sie es mitbekommen. Ich finde es einfach scheiße.
So fehlende Anteilnahme, so Desinteresse, dann wird es alles kompliziert. Und Polizei und so und der Nachbar ist ja eigentlich gelassen.
In Deutschland sind die zu 100% oder zu 80% die meisten Deutschen Augen zu und durch. Ich habe nichts gesehen, ich weiß von nichts, lasse mich in Ruhe.
Beziehungsweise es interessiert mich nicht, es ist mir zu kompliziert.
Und das finde ich so asozial. Das heißt doch immer, weiß ich nicht, es wird doch schon so viel Promoganda gemacht, von wegen Schauten, mach dies, mach das.
Und das ist genau das, was diese Internet-Twitter eben nicht macht, das Wegschauen. Das habe ich verstanden.
Ist ja vollkommen okay. Ich meine, deswegen ist ja auch eine Sendung wie diese und viele andere da und viele Weblogs, die sich genau mit dem Thema beschäftigen, um ein bisschen dahinter zu gucken und zu erklären, worum es da eigentlich geht.
Was ich halt gut fand, von einem von meinen Vorsprechern, von wegen hier mit diesen auf der Internetseite Hinweise, so du bist jetzt darauf gegangen, morgen steht das BKA vor deiner Haustür und nimmt dich mit. Find ich gut. Sollte man vielleicht auch.
Alles klar. Chris, danke dir für deinen Anruf und gute Nacht noch. 0331 70 97 110. Wir geben die Frage, wie informiert, führt er euch eigentlich über das Thema, oder geht er mal weiter nach Köln zu Mark? Guten Abend, Mark.
Schönen guten Abend.
Bist du im Thema drin, oder hast du auch nur die Schlagzeilen? Unsere Arzttechnik interessiert mich nicht.
Absolut im Thema drin. Mich hat dann, das war letzte Woche, auf heise.de irgendwo der Schlag getroffen, da hab ich gelesen, dass die eine Live-Überwachung wollten. Das hat dann ziemlich stark meine Interesse auf sich gezogen und hab dann halt mal ein bisschen die Threads verfolgt und mehr als zuvor bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung gekotzt. Letzten Endes, es wird rhetorisch von der Frau von der Leyen doch recht interessant und gut verkauft. Und sehr stark, wie ihr auch gesagt habt, emotional besetzt. Natürlich ist das ein Totschlagargument und mit dem Argument Kinderpornografie kann man einen sehr starken Hebel ansetzen, um Überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten. Aber das Problem, was ich hauptsächlich sehe, ist eigentlich, wie schafft man es den Leuten, die keinen Bock auf Fachbegriffe haben aus dem Technikbereich, zu den Leuten durchzudringen. Und ja, nicht, dass hier eine Aktion gestartet wird, da eine Aktion gestartet wird, sondern dass den Leuten klargemacht wird. Ja, wir haben eine Geschichte in Deutschland, eine Gewaltenteilung macht Sinn. Und dass hier alles jetzt nun beim BKA in einer Instanz verinnerlicht ist, dass ich noch nicht mal nachprüfen dürfte.
Weil die Liste nicht offiziell ist?
Richtig und das heißt ja auch, dass ich nicht nachprüfen dürfte, recherchieren dürfte, auch wenn ich Anwalt oder Journalist bin, ob das Ganze denn nur rechtmäßig war. Und das Fehler passieren sah man in Finnland, als das W3C, also dieses World Wide Web Konsortium, letztes Jahr im September gespeuert wurde. Also Fehler passieren, wo Menschen dran sind, das ist normal. Das ist mit wirtschaftlichen Schäden. Natürlich frage ich mich, was kann ich machen? Also ich kotze, um es auf den Punkt zu bringen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das hier legitim ist, diese Wörter im Radio zu gebrauchen.
Markus Köln spricht jetzt Wörter.
Entschuldigung, ich versuche mich zu Maßregeln. Ja, was kann man machen? Ich habe gesagt, Vorratsdatenspeicherung hat hier nicht viel zu suchen. Ich stimme zu, ist auch nur ein kleiner Bestandteil davon, weil BKA speicherte nicht, das wird ja beim Internet Service Provider gemacht.
Genau, aber die Entwicklung ist schon interessant, dass erst die Vorratsdatenspeicherung kam und jetzt geht es weiter. Die kleinen Puzzle-Steine bauen sich so zusammen, ne?
Absolut richtig. Das einzig interessante ist bei der Frage, was kann ich tun, kann man nur empfehlen, weil das Wort auch so einfach ist, Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die da gibt es eine Liste von Sachen, die man machen kann. Ich habe meinem Abgeordneten oder meiner Abgeordneten hier auch schon geschrieben. Lustigerweise, ich bin nicht der Erste gewesen, ist immer noch unbeantwortet. Aber interessanterweise, wenn man da ein bisschen weiter schaut auf diese Abgeordneten-Watch-Seite, sieht man, da scheint wirklich ein paar Leute zu interessieren. Bis dato habe ich es immer nur auf irgendwelchen privaten Foren gesehen. Glücklicherweise bei Spiegel Online haben sie vom Heiseforum einen Artikel eins zu eins übernommen. Und ich denke mal, das könnte der erste Schritt sein. Man sieht dann auch in den Mediatheken vom ZDF-3-Satz auch ein paar Statements.
Genau, der richtige Punkt ist schon, du hast es dann bei heise.de und im Forum von dem Portal gelesen.
Das darf nicht geek bleiben, das muss die Leute erreichen.
Ja, und das ist aber total geek, weil es erreicht eben relativ wenig Leute. Es gibt dann morgen wieder in der Zeitung eine riesen Schlagzeile und vielleicht zwei O-Töne aus einer Pressekonferenz rausgeschnitten und damit ist das Ding breit getreten. Und wir, glaube ich, nähern uns in den letzten zwei Stunden genau dem Problem so genähert, dass viel zu wenig darüber bekannt wird, was da eigentlich passiert. Nibler, mir gefällt immer noch das Bild mit der Salamischelbe, die du gebracht hast.
Ja, oder was ich auch gelesen habe, sehr treffend, finde ich, eine Seite aus dem Telefonbuch rausreißen und glauben, dass die Nummer nicht mehr da ist. Also das ist ein Schwachsinn. Na ja, gut, auf jeden Fall, und wie man das Ganze halt bündeln kann letzten Endes. Und die Möglichkeiten des Einzelnen sind sicher limitiert, aber letzten Endes, man hat einen Computer, wenn man sich aufregt und dann kann man eben Redaktionen schreiben, dann kann man seine Abgeordneten fragen und danach haken, das sind einmal die Sachen. Man kann im Privatkreis, im Bekanntenkreis, wo man da nicht automatisch den Stempel aufgedrückt bekommt, aha, du bist also einer, der dafür bist. Und dass man also da schon mal die richtige Bühne hat und nicht gleich abgestempelt wird, muss man sich halt die Zeit nehmen und den Leuten das erklären, um was es da eigentlich geht. Und dass die ersten Begehrlichkeiten auch schon geweckt sind und dass das der erste Anfang ist, letzten Endes. Und ja, dass hier ein Teil von Rechtsstaatlichkeit doch irgendwo gerade ziemlich billig verkauft wird.
Da waren ganz, ganz viele schlaue Sachen dabei, was du gesagt hast, Mark. Und ich fand überhaupt keine schlimmen Wörter.
Ja, ich hab mich auf Maß geregelt.
Eine andere Frage an Andreas von Nibbler, weil Mark hat es gerade ganz schön angesprochen, dass man was tun kann. Wie groß ist denn momentanes Arbeitsaufkommen beim Chaos Computer Club zu dem Thema? Wie viele Anfragen kriegt ihr denn pro Tag? Weil natürlich werdet ihr auch als Experten rangezogen, zum Interviews geben, Pressemeldungen schreiben und so.
Also, wenn das Thema gerade aktuell ist, werden wir ziemlich überschwemmt. Dann kommen da so viele Anfragen rein, dass wir teilweise nicht mehr antworten können und sagen, ne, das wird leider nichts mehr mit dem Interview heute.
Das Problem ist halt, dass sich das auch in eher zwei Lager aufteilt. Zum einen der, ich nenne sie jetzt mal, Qualitätsjournalismus, aber naja, was man auch immer darunter verstehen will. Also Leute, die wirklich weiter denken, so das betrifft mich selbst als Journalisten, die das Thema versuchen, einfach dann darzustellen, weil es eben da diese Polarisierung gibt, weil es relativ einfach zu sagen ist, oh, gegen Kinderpornos ist toll. Und dann auf der anderen Seite natürlich eben die Leute, die eine Schlagzeile machen wollen, die sagen wollen, Kinderpornos, schreiben wir mal zwei, drei Sätze drüber und das wars dann. Aber die Komplexität des Themas, das Problem nicht rüberbringen können, ob der Komplexität.
Das Schlimme ist ja auch, ich bin bei der Suche und beim Surfen links und rechts auch über ein PDF-Dokument gestoßen, das letztendlich ein Gutachten ist, dass von Sachverständigen der Regierung, von der Regierung beauftragt, zur Verfügung gestellt wurde. Und das Fazit war letzten Endes, genau das, was der T9, die sind natürlich wie nicht anders zu erwarten, auch natürlich jetzt im Gremium des Chaos Computer Clubs, ist einfach, dass hier grundgesetzbezogen doch einige Bedenken zu äußern sind, dass die Wirksamkeit letzten Endes ein Witz ist. Und ich möchte mich gar nicht mit anderen DNS-Servern groß befassen. Ich möchte mich nicht mit irgendwelchen VPN-Tunneln befassen, weil letzten Endes damit ich schon akzeptiere, dass es so kommen wird und einfach nur quasi mit dem Fügel und dem Weg um das Problem herumsuche. Und ich sage halt Leute, das geht so nicht.
Lustig fand ich, was Frau von der Leyen zu diesem Gutachten gesagt hat. Sie hielt nämlich ein anderes Gutachten daneben und meinte, das ist viel dicker als dieses Dürre-Gutachten. Und deswegen ist das dicke Gutachten besser unterdrückt. Wirklich.
Ja, ein Donald Duck Buch ist auch dicker als das Grundgesetz.
Richtig. Marc, das ist ein großartiges Schlusswort gewesen. Danke dir.
Ich wünsche euch einen schönen Abend.
Nibler, wir müssen ja was noch ganz anderes machen. Du hast eine Musik mitgebracht. Was hören wir denn jetzt gleich?
Wir haben noch den Wetter voller Musik, oder?
Lass uns doch kurz in die Musik reinhören und dann machen wir den Wetter frosch. Oh, die CCC-Leute reden schräges Zeug. Lasst euch überraschen, was gleich passiert. Nebelarbeit ist es für eine Platte.
Das ist BZ da mit Kletzmer.
Ein Bild für Götter, zwei vor.
Und dazu begrüßen wir den Wetterforscher am Telefon. Wir haben da so eine Veranstaltung in Köln, habe ich gehört, und du organisierst die, erzähl doch mal ein bisschen.
Ich mache da auch ein bisschen mit. Genau, wir haben in Köln die SIGINT 09, Signal Interrupt, das ist von 22. bis 24. Mai in drei Wochen. Im Kölner Komet ist ein schickes Medienzentrum, direkt im Medienpark in der Innenstadt. Und da steht für Signal Intelligence, wie für Signal Interrupt, sind so die Assoziationen, die am Norden da kommen können. Es geht darum, Zeichen zu setzen, Signale für die Gesellschaft auch zu setzen, die sich mit Informationstechniken und dessen Folgen für die Gesellschaft und dessen Anwendungen in der Gesellschaft, die uns vielleicht eher so ein bisschen verborgen bleiben, beschäftigen. Also zum Beispiel, wie für Andreas auch, etwas über Signal Intelligence, also Geheimnistätigkeiten selbst gemacht, referieren, aber auch das ganze Thema der Internetzensur wird bei uns in vielen Veranstaltungen zur Sprache kommen.
Vielleicht muss man es noch dazu sagen, wir machen ja jedes Jahr den Chaos Communication Congress und das ist mittlerweile eine sehr internationale und vor allen Dingen auch sehr technische Veranstaltung geworden. Wir wollten die SIGINT, also eigentlich eher, die richtet sich an Publikum aus dem Land, also insbesondere an Journalisten und hat halt auch die Politik im Vordergrund. Also die Dinge, über die wir gerade geredet haben, mal am Stück Leuten vorzutragen.
Genau, wir sagen auch, dass die erste Veranstaltung, die sich jetzt nicht direkt speziell an die Hacker-Community oder Szene wendet, sondern eben an die Öffentlichkeit sich richtet und von uns gemacht wird und wo wir auch verschiedenste Projekte und Gruppen aus unserem Umfeld vorstellen wollen oder die Möglichkeit geben wollen, sich zu präsentieren. Und an der Stelle auch nochmal eingeladen, bin sympathisierende Gruppen aus unserem Umfeld und sich denken, oh, politische Themen innerhalb des CCCs werden mal diskutiert. So ein paar Plätze haben wir vielleicht noch für Stände oder einen Workshop.
Kann ich da auch als Autonormalverbraucher vorbeikommen?
Da kann man einfach vorbeikommen, geht drei Tage, kostet normal 60 Euro für Schüler 40 Euro.
Dann sag doch nochmal ganz schnell die Eckdaten bitte. Wann, Wo, Wie und Ohl.
22. bis 24. Mai in Köln, in der Innenstadt im Kölner Komet, SIGINTCCCDE, SIGINTCCCDE und alle möglichen Themen, die der Club eben zu bieten hat gesellschaftlicher Naturwände, präsentiert Datenschutz, Informationsfreiheit, Wikileaks, offene Regierungen oder irgendwie auch die ganze Urheberrechtsfrage, werden wir uns allen widmen und haben da auch eine freundliche Unterstützung von der Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung, das sollt ich vielleicht an der Stelle noch sagen.
Es gibt ja auch in diesen Tagen die ganze Menge zu diskutieren, deswegen euch viel Spaß an Köln. Danke dir, tschüss. Und danke euch auch fürs Zuhören in diesem Chaosradio Nr. 145. Noch mal hören geht selbstverständlich entweder auf fritz.de im Podcast oder aber auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Das nächste Chaosradio gibt es dann Ende Mai dann mit dem Kollegen Markus Richter, weil ich da Norwegen unsicher machen werde. Und wir hören uns dann im Juni wieder. Andreas und Nibbler, danke, dass ihr hier wart und kommt alle gut nach Hause. Vielen Dank.